and hello
hello everybody it's been a while i am back home now
everyone yay hello everyone name is super chat coolest party
thank you i got a small question for chat who's still
waiting for your dokey bird plus what's the dokey bird plus
name is super chat thank you thank you hello everyone hi i
like how high dokey can translate to doctor Hello!
That's right, Dr. Jokey Bird, MD.
Legally licensed.
I'm back, I'm so tired.
I don't remember how to stream anymore.
They're a very legitimate doctorate degree, for real, from a
very legitimate university.
I don't remember how to stream, guys.
I'm legit so tired.
at the moment.
I'm so exhausted.
Welcome back, Doki.
Do you remember to buy the milk?
Thank you, the super chat, Gus.
Thank you, thank you.
Gwail, thank you, the super chat.
Doki, we're so good.
They made another one.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm all over the place.
My brain is, like, so scattered at the moment.
There's, like, a million things for me to do.
I've been, I came back around Wednesday.
Was it Wednesday?
Yes.
on Wednesday finally got home I was supposed to stay in LA
for I was supposed to just relax in LA for like maybe like
till the 7th or 8th but then um then I got the tickets for
the more for the Columbia versus Switzerland game and I
heard it was like the last game in Canada so I was like fuck
I have to go back I was like, you hate watch Switzerland.
Literally, I know that didn't do much.
So I changed my flight tickets.
I changed my flight tickets on the 6th to, like, fly out on
the 6th.
I was supposed to fly out on the 8th.
So I changed it to fly out on the 6th.
So I could go to Vancouver and watch the Switzerland versus
Columbia game because Columbia was favored to win.
like everyone was so surprised about the results there no
you guys don't understand at the stadium um at the stadium
um it was at like 90 percent columbians uh it was all yellow
by the way there was only like one section that was like
just for like that was just red every it was a full house by
the way it was witch witch burner bring back the witch part
child's fucking witch
um yeah so um it was crazy oh smith thank you for the rain
we had a great stream and don't worry man I'll do the thing
that you told me to do I saw the message today um I don't
tell you what it is though i'll never tell okay oh yes all
the ibu's had a great time um watching what was it fendango
the one with the skellies the skellies right uh thank you
for the rain i was telling everybody about uh back back home
now um so yeah so uh the world cup game the last game in cat
it was a full house so there was like 52 000 people in the
stadium i got a really good seat because time, I was like,
this is the last game.
I should get the middle seat this time.
it was crazy, because like I said, it was like 90%
Colombians.
Literally a sea of yellow outside the stadium and
everything.
I joined in this, like, people were like, like the, even
when Colombia lost, it was two days ago, right?
The games were two days ago.
Even when Colombia lost, they were still playing Colombian
music, like outside the stadium, like the, like the the,
what was it, the fan festival outside of stadium.
It was still just, they were just playing Columbia music
still, and everybody was still just dancing.
It was nice to see.
It was nice to see, you know, even though they lost,
everyone was just, like, still celebrating Columbia.
Yeah, no, I was at the stadium for, it was, I had to,
because it was literally the, yeah, the party never, I was
so scared of riots, because apparently from, I don't know if
this was true, let me Google this.
uh let me google this i wasn't sure because my friend told
me about it um oh yeah so apparently i was really worried
because like um if people for those who don't know vancouver
is known for riots so yeah vancouver is very well known for
riots so we've had a lot of riots in vancouver So like, I
was really scared because, um, because I, because like, you
know, it was like a lot, there was a lot of people at the
World Cup and I was at the stadium.
I was at the stadium.
So I was so scared because I was at the stadium and then the
fan favorite lost.
So I was like, oh no.
And then the witch, the witch cursed us.
And so I was like, oh no.
So luckily there was no riots.
Thank God because apparently from Apparently my friend was
like are you okay, and I was like I'm fine.
There's no riots anyway, so I was worried because my friend
was like Messaged me my friend texted me and was like are
you okay?
I heard people got shot after?
Mexico came and I was like oh my Because apparently, after
the Mexico game, there was sort of like a soft riot.
Not like a riot riot, but there was a soft riot after the
Mexico game.
And apparently people were getting, got shot there.
Like, and I was like, oh, luckily I'm in Canada.
Like, yeah, yeah.
Luckily, I'm in Canada.
Yeah, so I was like, yeah.
I hope it was unrelated.
related so i i got a little paranoid yeah yeah so so there
was no rat there was a lot dancing though there was there
was some dancing outside the stadium um so um i was a little
sad because i was if colombia won there would have been a
party you know there would have been like a parade and party
very very sad people after the game in it i felt so bad
after because like where i was sitting um it was like front
left well to be fair my left and right were mostly like um
rich white people i don't know how else to describe it my
front left and right were rich white people but then my and
my front front were like yeah Columbia okay it was like my
left was some obviously like some posh white guy who like he
seemed very posh who brought his girlfriend with him and she
was definitely not interested in the game she was definitely
not interested in the game because she did not know what the
fuck was going on and then the posh white like okay and then
the posh white dude was wearing like earplugs and stuff
because it was it was very i didn't worry i just did it raw
i was just like let's just let's just embrace the energy
like and yeah and then so he was wearing earplugs too he was
a fucking coward that's what i'm gonna say he was weak as
hell right but guys thank you Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Yeah, I was wrong.
I'm tanking it.
It was very loud, by the way.
I was with Melly.
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you.
Yo, I was with Doki Doki Rewind.
It was awesome.
The little bit of scuff at the beginning had me worried, but
the rest of the show blew my mind.
It's Rewind Time.
Hey, it's called Doki Doki Rewind Time.
It was Rewind Time.
No, I don't worry.
I was also very stressed out about that, too.
Love the fun things you added, like 99 Red Blooms.
Thank you for the content.
thank you super chat thank you thank you so um it was really
funny because like he was trying to explain to his
girlfriend about the game and clearly she did not really
understand she was just like on like there like on her phone
and stuff so then he started talking to me about the game
because i was just like oh because i was making i obviously
i was like doing like small commentary like oh like you know
i was watching it because he was just like oh what file was
it like blah blah blah and then so he started talking to me
because i actually like understood the game and um and then
i was like making jokes and stuff and was like oh because
like at one point i don't remember which goalie was i don't
know it was colombia's goalie or uh switzerland's goalie but
they ran out i was like oh my god he's gonna pull a usa uh
by the way i was still in the states when that game was
going on i was in a restaurant maybe a bad idea it was i i
would was i was a little scared people were so angry during
the us game like people were so angry uh during the usa game
like i saw i saw that you the goalkeeper and you did the
thing live um yeah yeah the third goal yeah um so i saw that
in a right and still in the united states of america in the
restaurant slash bar by the way it was a bar slash
restaurant which was not the brightest idea from my end to
go to I legit forgot what time it was when the game started
I was just like hungry so I forgot what time it was so I
didn't realize the US game was playing while all of this was
going on so yeah it was got a little got a little rough
there it got a little round Yeah, it was sort of slow-key a
sports bra So I wasn't very smart in my decision In going
there Uh, Krish, thank you Uh, thank you for 10 Get the
shows, thank you, thank you Um, so yeah Um, I thought it was
funny Um But, uh I got, I was in the wave This time I get to
be part of the wave, you know Like I got There was a never
ending wave That lasted like three waves I was like praying
to God it would stop Like I was just like, please, someone
stop the wave.
It's been going on too long.
I was just like, it went on for three laps around the
stadium.
I thought I was like, stop the wave.
I, please stop.
Great.
Thank you.
Super chat.
pit joy oh my god was there really i didn't realize there
was i didn't see the mosh pit thank you super chat thank you
thank you i got ragdog hard being the smallest to join in
great thank you the super chat thank you thank you cool
thank you the super chat thank you thank you cried so hard
when mexico got out those 11 extra minutes gave me hope also
my last message it was supposed to say don't keep it very
flashy thank you for the super chat thank you i'm sorry
everyone i'm sorry i didn't do a watch a lot guys maybe okay
every game i don't do a watch along the team loses maybe
that's the thing maybe that's the curse if i don't do a
watch along your team loses i'm sorry i was in l.a i
couldn't stream guys i couldn't stream gordon thank you the
akasupa thank you thank you which I'm a reverse witch.
Happy birthday, turkey bread.
I'm late, but I was carrying, busy carrying many back to the
hotel, but the concert was amazing.
Every song was a banger.
You may not see yourself in this idol, but you are a bright,
shiny star.
I hope you enjoyed the gift.
I love what you're said.
Thank you, Naka, soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, I got a bunch of your gifts, guys.
It's in my bag.
I haven't had, as always, I haven't had a chance to unpack
anything.
I have seen your messages in the chat.
like for those who for those who don't know um at the
concert we had a giant uh giant what's it called banner
there for people to write birthday messages to me um i had
to unroll it and flip the thing because i had to it didn't
fit in my suitcase so it was like a giant roll like it was
just a giant banner thing um and i obviously like i couldn't
put in my suitcase so i had to dokey dokey rewind time on
it's like to reverse it and re-roll it and everything so the
the back of it is facing like people uh but um it's it's
back i have it i have it i didn't read all the messages on
there's so many messages but thank you so much for the
birthday messages guys uh but again thank you thank you for
the aquasupa uh gordon thank you thank you thank you thank
you i wanted to join that marsh bit so bad but so stopped as
soon as i jumped in the super chat many thank you thank you
i know that fucking witch it's okay i think the funny for
those who don't know the story behind the witch there was in
there's an indie vtuber out there uh where every team she
supported lost and uh the entire round of 16 by the way but
the curse was finally broken um because of Mbappe.
She supported France.
And the curse was finally broken.
Dictator Mbappe is just truly stronger.
And of course, she went six, seven.
Everyone did not, you know, Mbappe's too strong.
The curse has been the saint Mbappe slayed the witch.
yeah wait did he get injured that was the curse
that was the curse guy the dead general and poppin
she did take him out I didn't realize that he got injured I
didn't watch I didn't watch a lot yeah he sacrificed himself
to break the curse I didn't watch the Morocco versus France
game.
Well, I had it running in the side, but it was like 0-0
half-time.
And I was like, oh, no, the curse.
Because I was like, you know, statistically wise, France
should be a lot better than Morocco.
So I was so surprised they managed to get 0-0 for that long.
And then so then I was just like, okay, 0-0.
And I had a lot of work to do as well.
So I was just like, okay, I didn't focus on work and stuff.
Yeah, so I was just like, all right, zero, zero, whatever.
Maybe those score and second half, but I have stuff to do.
Yeah, and then he also missed the penalty kick as well.
So I was just like, bro.
I was like, the curse.
Yeah, he even missed the penalty kick.
I saw that.
I was like, oh, shit, that's a fucking good ass penalty.
And then he missed it.
And I was like, all right, okay, the curse.
It's taking an effect now.
yeah um um so i watched a little of that but like i said i i
felt like oh i don't know the first half was i will say the
first half was a really boring game so so i was just like um
yeah i was just like oh i don't know i didn't really want to
watch it after that the it wasn't really that engaging for
me the the colombia versus switzerland game i swear to okay
wait i need to know how many passes so like statistically
wise i was thinking well france statistically is a lot
better than morocco so uh morocco play haram if you think
that was haramba watch switzerland versus colombia how many
passes colombia i had to watch that live.
I had to watch the Switzerland versus Columbia Harambaugh
live, not just once, but twice.
They did that to Canada too.
I had to watch them do it live twice versus Canada and
Columbia.
You think I had fun?
I got fucking tortured live.
That was, no, no, you don't, that was so, bro, every time
they start passing, the sea of Colombians started booing,
and I joined in, I, every, you don't, I know it was a ramba,
because every time they start passing, I just hear, boo.
Like, every time...
They're like...
Boo!
That is huge shit.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired of Harab.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where's the passes, stats?
Where the fuck is my pass stats?
Did no one keep track of the passes?
I...
...
I'm trying to look all right pat oh my god 631 I Columbia
started doing it too like 631 passes from Switzerland's
that's too many passes that's way too many passes give it
the Lord
Columbia by the way by the way the first half Columbia was
like gas gas gas gas gas and then the second half Columbia
joined in on the passes um it was 547 um passes from
Columbia but Switzerland had 631 yeah they could do more
that's that's the thing Columbia had insane actually no
Columbia passes were like more so
show of like uh they're passing near the goal yeah it was
like they were passing near the goal to shoot but
switzerland was mostly just passing between goalkeeper to
left then back to goalkeeper then back to right then back to
goalkeeper left left then right back to goalkeeper left left
right back to goalkeeper and i swear to god i was gonna run
into that field and punch someone i i swear to god i wanted
i wanted to send someone one down and just stop the game.
Just,
you don't understand.
Watching that live is torture.
I, I, I, and I have to watch, I'm sorry, people are like,
why are you so against Switzerland?
This is their first time getting passed around of 16 in 70
plus years.
You didn't have to watch that live.
on the stadium like not only did i have to watch slishlin do
that once i don't watch them do it twice at the stadium i
and they knocked out canada from home field that could have
been canada's field like
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm
currently manifesting that the Canadian national team will
now employ Haramba as their main strat.
They use the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, you are just salty.
I just guys, I'm just oh my, okay, it's like it's fun when
it's like they had some exciting that game.
Could have been that game had some exciting moments, but by
God, when they slow it when they're slow, Wait, I have to
watch like, like 10 minutes straight of just passing back at
their home field.
Like, I get it.
It's, yeah, it's, it's fun when it's your team.
No, I should talk Canada for haram balling.
I was like, this is piss poor soccer.
What the fuck am I watching?
I, what do you mean, you did not like that?
500 pass in the back lane bro someone nerfed this fucking
meta this shit is ass like i need a hot fix patch right now
everybody um uh but yeah anyway so i saw that at the stadium
uh you want to get okay back it was the last 10 minutes it's
fine when it's the last 10 minutes Not the entire fucking
game, guys.
I saw in the first half.
I was seeing, they went, guys, they had to play an extra
game.
They had, they had like 30 minutes extra of more Haramball,
guys.
And I had to watch, I had to watch not only 90 minutes of
Haramball.
I had to watch 120 minutes of Haramball, which is worse than
10.
10 minutes of a wrong ball.
Yeah.
Anyway, penalties was crazy, though.
I feel bad because, like, I think, like, the Colombian, I
felt like the Colombian goalkeeper is better than
Switzerland's goalkeeper.
I'm sorry for everyone who doesn't watch sports.
I'm sorry.
This is a jock.
Nourers, go back to the locker.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Harawa's equivalent triple supported.
Marva arrivals.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry, nerds.
This is like this is Normie's territory right now.
We're talking about sports, bro.
This is just a jock thing, you know.
Yeah, go hit the shower, nerds.
Bro, everyone.
America regions are knocked out.
Come is gone.
At this point, we have to call it football.
They deserved it now.
But anyway, so, what was I saying?
I think Colombia's goalkeeper is better than Switzerland's
goalkeeper.
Because, like, Switzerland, technically, for those who
didn't know, Switzerland, a goalkeeper, won Man of the Match
or whatever.
Player of the Match.
I don't fucking remember what it's called.
with a match or some shit but i felt like columbia's
goalkeeper was so much better than switzerland's goalkeeper
only because they blocked cooler shots like they blocked
shots that were much more intense than switzerland like i'm
sorry but like when i was watching like columbia fumbled so
many shots it was like they had insane passes and then they
just fumbled it at the end yeah it was so sad to watch like
they it's either they like shot too far like out of bounds
or like they shot it into the goalkeeper's hands which was
so sad to watch in person because i was like holy like
everybody was standing up the moment like um one of the
colombian strikers uh got the ball and it was like whoa you
know everyone's standing up to watch it but they like the
passes were fucking insane like it was actually insane
passes and then they fumbled it during the shot like it was
so Switzerland, they didn't fumble their pass.
They didn't, they fumble their passes, but their shots were
so good.
Like they had insane shots too, uh, from Switzerland, but
the goalkeeper blocked everything.
It was crazy.
But then he didn't, but then he didn't block when it
matters, which was penalties, which was the sad part.
Like, I felt so bad.
He had all these amazing blocks, um, during the actual game.
And then when it came, came the penalties he blocked none of
them I felt so bad watching that yeah I was just like oh man
the only time the ball didn't get in was when the guy missed
yeah yeah penalties are so hard yeah he was on cool town
yeah when it actually mattered he ulted too soon um yeah I
don't know you guys like for those who didn't watch it it
was so sad to watch because um the Switzerland keeper um
blocked like two really good pk shots i didn't think columb
i i closed my eyes for some of them but i watched the replay
and i was just like yeah it was so it was just a little uh
it was a little sad to watch like when i did open my eyes it
was just sad just like because like i think i personally
because it was so stressful
stressful.
I've done PKs before.
I used to be a goalkeeper.
So like, I know how much pressure it is to play as
goalkeeper.
So I could feel the pressure and the stress, especially when
like the stadium was like 90% Colombian.
So like I felt the stress from all the Colombians around me.
So like, I like, like, I like felt the pressure in the air
type deal.
Um, And so, like, even though I'm not Colombian, I, like, I
felt the stress from it.
Like, the stress in the air.
105, a good save rate for PKs.
Yeah, but the guy didn't even save anything.
The one ball he did save.
The one ball that didn't get in was because the guy missed.
the one the one goal that the colombian goal curious save is
just because the guy missed the goal so it wasn't even like
it didn't even save he didn't even save it like yeah
yeah um uh and what was i oh yeah what was i say yeah uh
want to say before but it was so sad because like i said i
think it's harder um i think it's harder to play um when
you're on home field even though like i know like it's still
in canada but there is like like i said the stadium was like
90 percent columbian i think like it's definitely a lot more
pressure when you're on home field just because like uh
you're you worried about supporting you and everything so
like i feel so bad for colombia because like after the game
was over like they were crying on the field i was like oh no
like some of them were just lying on the floor like
contemplating life and i saw them like i saw some of them
were actually crying and everything and i was just like oh
my god like i i know i felt so bad because like i was just
like oh no
is just like lying on the floor just like contemplating life
after and then on those right hand side you see so just like
yeah yeah yeah the tournament pressure yeah it's just rough
another four years jacano thank you the super chat thank you
thank you thank you who needs esbn sport comedy when you got
doki covering what you need to know we joke about doki
playing a fifa game before but and how she would manage team
all my teams would lose i'm so bad at stats then you super
chat thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you game
upon would have been more entertaining thank you for super
chat thank you thank you mike thank you super chat thank you
oh i already read that but thank you again um yeah i was in
the city when mexico lost so i understand experience yeah um
but yeah anyway i'm gonna show you guys wait let me show you
guys the video it was so cool it was fun though like before
colombia lost everyone was so happy well after colombia lost
people were still partying else well not a lot of people
partying outside because like i said like um let's see uh
but there were still some people partying let me see i can
find the video of the party this one i really don't want to
show maybe this one let me see yeah it infiltrated the
colombian dance circle outside the stadium before the game
was about to start um let me turn there you go
Woo!
Sorry, it was loud.
Yeah, look at everybody partying!
Yeah, they were partying hard.
Yeah, it was like, there was like, there was like, like, it
was just basically a DJ, just like, playing like, Colombian
music, and everybody was just, like, just partying, and I
was just like, yeah!
uh oh wait thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
it's me and the dude tamaru will get named soon so you can't
say we're fans of dubry's next concert wait aren't you guys
dupers now i like how it's not dubry it's dupers thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you uh i have my phone i
basically like extending my arm all the way up and just
recorded it
yeah i saw a doobie saying duper thanks for helping kenny to
regain the aw world championship saw some dragons and crouch
him oh that's so cute i didn't know you guys were there too
yeah i saw that on twitter i was like oh my god he won
that's what a coincidence i gave him a shout is that kenny
omega and then he won the thing you know maybe i am good
luck uh i think it was super chat wait thank you thank you
oh and i'll wait uh burger coon thank you my super chat
thank you thank you what else i show you guys other stuff
too um let's see oh my god i felt uh let's see um let me see
where is it but um oh yeah for the last the last uh the last
day at i know i was talking i should be talking more of the
concert stuff, but like the most recent one.
Let's talk about what I remember most recently, which is the
World Cup campsite.
Let me see.
Yeah, no, I can't play this video on stream because I don't
want to get a highway to hell.
They got that guy.
I don't remember guy who made the Highway-to-Hell song to
like sing at the stadium.
At first, like, I didn't realize what the song was when they
start playing it because, like, you know, I didn't realize,
like, what the lyrics are.
And he's like, Highway-to-Hell, bomb.
And he's like, oh my God, it's Highway-to-Hell.
Yeah.
I just know that lyric part of the song.
Is it Highway-to-Hell?
Let me double check.
Maybe it wasn't Highway to Hell.
Little check.
It was not Highway to Hell.
It's another song.
Wait, I'm sorry.
I got my songs confused.
It's been a while.
Let me listen to this.
Sorry.
Life is a highway.
Bum, bada, nana, all night long.
That song.
Sorry.
I got my highway songs confused.
I got my, sorry.
I got my highway songs.
songs confused.
They both have highways in it.
So I was like, is it how the hell?
I had to re-listen to it.
And I was like, oh shit, I had to record it.
It's like, life is the highway.
On that log.
Yeah, not the high.
There's too many highway songs.
Wrong highway.
Sorry.
That's the car song.
Yeah, I had the car song played.
um anyway they invited that band uh they he was old so i
assume it was the original singer i i just knew that it was
it was old so i knew that was the original singer because i
was like oh i it's like a very i know that was a very old
song i like i was like oh man i could i was looking to zoom
in from the cameras uh yeah yeah we're on the highway by the
way so i think that's the original singer because of how old
he was um so so he was in he was singing there um what else
i'm gonna show you guys like the national like columbia's
national anthem being played but was i got worried i was
like what if i get struck down like what what if i get
struck down for playing the colombian national anthem on my
on my stream i have 14 seconds of it but let me double check
uh i'll give you guys 14 seconds of it i'll crop this a
little bit though i have 14 seconds of it recorded give me a
sec guys
oh no no all right let me send this to myself
i'm like so relaxed right now i don't remember how to stream
guys it's been a while colombia issues a copyright strike
if i get copyright strike i hope it's from colombia
all right let me double check this video
whoa all right here you guys go
yeah there was like i said there was a lot of colombia like
90 percent colombians i got the ending of it
yeah see it's majority yellow fantastic except you can see a
sprinkle of red you can see a sprinkle of red here and there
i was not joking by the way you know what's funny though um
um i was in the i was in one of the i was in the hospitality
seats uh again um because i wanted to buy i wanted to have a
good view um and it was so funny because in the host oh my
gosh like in the hospitality seats majority of people there
were not colombian or so and i would see people wearing
their canadian jerseys you know because they're like i don't
know who i'm just gonna wear my canadian jersey that was
funny i thought it was so funny yeah i just i just noticed
like um maturity people there i think they were just
canadians i don't think they were like colombian or swiss
because you would think you know if you're colombian you
would wear the you would wear the i think they were here to
hate watch Switzerland too.
Yeah.
I think, I think they were there to hate watch Switzerland
too, because a lot of them were just wearing, I saw like
half of them were wearing the Canadian jersey.
So they were like me, I'm just here to hate watch
Switzerland.
My fellow, My fellow hate watchers.
Yeah.
Yeah, my my enthusiast.
Um, what was I going to talk about?
From other, before I go to the concert stuff.
Um, the hate watch army.
Yeah.
Um.
By the way, I was curious.
So, for those who don't know, I will tell you guys that the
Canadian hospitality tickets are much cheaper than the ones
in America.
I don't know about Mexico, though, because I didn't check
the Mexico ticket prices.
I'm so sorry.
I'll talk about the concert after this part, because I have
some stuff to show you guys from the concert.
But I'm just going through, like, recent memories.
I flew home early, flew back to Canada early, just so I
could hate watch the last game in Canada.
Yeah, so you guys are like, wow, I can't believe you spent
so much money on hospitality tickets.
The hospitality tickets in Canada are so much cheaper
compared to the US because I was curious about the
hospitality tickets and how much it would be like if I, you
know, if I want to watch the finals or the semis or
whatever.
So like, you know, I just, I was curious, I wasn't going to
actually because like i didn't want to keep flying i'm like
really tired of flying right now um so um so for those who
don't know i checked the hospitality tickets for the finals
in new york city and it's it's 30 000 for one ticket for for
the finals one ticket is 30 fucking grand and the cheapest
ticket there was the cheapest ticket for the finals was
18,000 dollars for one ticket I was like oh my god no that
looked at the semis the semis the semis was half of that was
like 20k instead of 30k it was 20k I was like are you
fucking kidding I was like oh my god
like those are hospitality tickets so those are like the
like the ones with lounges I don't know what the prices are
like for um for like the regular tickets with no lounges or
anything no I didn't fucking buy one fucking course now what
the fuck like I don't I'm not gonna fly New York just so
Yeah, I'm watching at home.
I'm watching with you guys.
The fuck?
Like, the only reason why I bought tickets for Canada was
that I know it was cheaper than watching in America.
And also, like, I went to watch the last game in Canada,
too.
Because, like I said, we don't know whenever Canada is going
to host another World Cup during my time.
So during my lifetime, I don't know when I'll ever see
Canada host the World Cup.
And, like, you know, have a chance to experience that again
so i that's why that's the only reason why i bought the
tickets to watch and it's a lot cheaper than america so yeah
and it's a lot cheaper there too so i was just like i might
as well like i can easily travel to bc place to fucking
watch a game yeah um it's like once a lifetime opportunity
but not that i'm gonna want i don't want it that badly i
don't like she had to give us super chat thank you thank you
um jokie when cumler cumlumbia lost by the sd curse i had
made a bet that columbia were to lose i would eat my
columbian no no why would you ever bet against sd thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you one of my friends was
just like columbia's gonna win columbia's gonna win we're so
good statistically we are the favorites we're so get by and
i was like i see cursed you guys though he's like no that's
not gonna happen that's not gonna happen we're gonna break
the curse he was just like there's no way columbia's the
favorite right now he there's so there's so much of a better
team there's no i was like i was like she retweeted i was
like she tweeted it he was coping so hard and then when
columbia lost he was just like that That fucking whore!
Fuck that whore!
She was too, I was like, I was like, which?
Witch!
She sealed the deal with that tweet, the witch.
Burn the witch!
Bring back the witch trap!
Burner
Gordon, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you
Bro, you can have a good condition Use card, tickets to a
football game with Haramba For 75% of the match Thank you
for the super chat, thank you, thank you Yes, but you can
see Holland, though of tickets to the finals you might be
able to see hotend guys thank you super chat thank you thank
you forget to mention receive my anniversary merch try to
pay groceries my dokey coin but they didn't accept it do you
think i was scabbed no it's because they realized how good
um they realized that um they don't you you pay too much and
they didn't want to scam you you know they didn't want to
scam you because they were like oh man this dokey coin would
have been worth a hundred Then they're like, we can't scam
that poor man.
I can't take your coin.
Gus, they gave it a super chat.
Thank you.
They're trying to make sure you, like they didn't scam you.
Yeah, they didn't have enough change.
Exactly.
They didn't have enough change for the Doki coin.
So they couldn't accept it.
Yeah, they don't have a change for a single Doki coin.
The currency conversion rate is too high.
it's okay the curse is broken i think the curse only lasts
till round of end of round of 16 what else was i gonna say
um what was i gonna say about the the games before i move on
to like uh i wrote all my notes here um oh yeah it was
so all right so I'm in a little weird situation.
I hate Switzerland.
But then I realized they're against Argentina.
And I don't hate Argentina.
But also, I'm in a weird situation.
I will say I do hate Switzerland.
If you're from Switzerland, I don't hate you.
I hate...
I hate Switzerland.
She needs to...
I just...
Guys, you don't understand.
Your team plays Harambaugh.
Your team...
My hate is justified.
I have to sit through two games of Harambaugh in person.
I...
I do, you don't understand.
I, so, I didn't, so, I didn't, I forgot that they're playing
against Argentina.
Tank the Switzerland win for the rest of the world.
Papa Smur, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
She hates good football.
Fucking get that shit away from me.
If you say, there's no way you can justify her.
Rambla is good football.
There's no way like There's no way you can say that
So I'm in a little bit of a predict your predicament here
Because I I hate Yeah, don't you yeah, that's just fucking
rage bait.
That's just fucking rage bait here
be that's why
okay so anyway I will say okay I will I think everybody's
team Holland right I like how also I don't know if you guys
saw this but Holland tweeted out Google technically he
tweeted out Google me he'll say Google made a special
Holland uh celebration thing a Google doodle just for him um
but i think we can all agree that we're all team holland
right no matter what your thoughts are on other teams i'm
sorry england but come on i'm team england sadly they
defeated mexico yeah but like but then but come on bro come
on what's you know what's better better anything's better
than british miku but you don't
You know, it's better than the British Miku, guys.
Norwegian Miku.
It's not coming home.
Come on, guys.
No matter what, at least we're all united with Holland.
She's not right.
I'm sorry, but Holland.
Bro, that man is genetically engineered to play soccer slash
football.
He's just, he's literally, he's like bred to be a football
player.
The Miku custody battle.
So yeah, no matter what, we're all team, we're all team
Holland.
DeFrost, they had to put him in the freezer after the World
Cup.
Man, no matter what, yeah, we're all team Holland.
Yeah, his mom, um, Oh, yeah, for those who didn't know, I
had a tour of the Riot Studio.
All right, so yeah, let me...
Sorry.
All right, let's do...
Let's talk concert, because I'm getting distracted with
the...
Like, I'm getting distracted with everything I was doing in
LA.
So let's talk about the concert, and then we'll go back
to...
We'll go back to Football and also Riot Studio.
But...
I am in talks with Riot staff.
If we can get a streamed Riot Studio tour.
It was, like, a joke.
first shout out to jessica sorry shout out to jennifer
roberts not jessica shout out to jennifer roberts uh for uh
jennifer roberts husband for getting us a tour of rise here
for those who don't know um jennifer roberts husband uh is
one of the is the voice actor like the casting director
slash i think that's what it is i don't know maybe i'm
sitting around but like he basically helps cast voice actors
for the new champions and stuff for um all the riot games so
like league tft um all those games he does like the hit like
her husband does is the casting director for it so um he got
me amalie um and jennifer roberts uh tour of riot studio and
then he was such a good tour guide because he was like it
was so interesting for those who didn't know the campus of
riot studio is based off of the league map so like there's
like top mid top lane middle lane and bottom lane and jungle
so like that's how the campus is um that's how the campus
architecture looks like so if you have a drone at looking at
top down looking down at the right studio you will see top
middle and bottom lane in the courtyard because the
courtyard is like yeah And then, like, the cafeteria is the
Summoner's Rift.
I thought that was so funny.
They're like, yeah, the cafeteria is the Rift.
So, yeah, it's really cool.
So, like, I was like, oh, you're such a good tour guide.
I was like, yo, can I invite you to my stream?
And, like, can I invite you to my stream and you can explain
all this?
Because I feel like I couldn't explain it properly.
yeah I feel like I couldn't explain this properly so I was
just like I would love for you to be on my stream and then
we could do like a and then like you know I have pictures
and just like you just explain stuff or like I took pictures
of the ride studio and he could just explain everything
while I show you guys picture and then he was like bro I
could use like I could do you better whatever you do a work
you if you can send someone over um you know with the like
the iPad stuff Where I'm on like an iPad or like a little
monitor And then he could do like a virtual stream tour for
us But this won't be like very soon We have to like, because
he gets permission and stuff But he said it's possible So
it'd be like a couple of weeks later Yeah, so a free tour
for you guys at Rise Studio Because I can't explain the
stuff he's saying It was so cool Did you guys know that a
lot of like studios They have these have like falconers Is
that what I saw those like falcon people Like people who
train Falcons and stuff.
Because they don't want like bird pooping at the campus.
So they would, like every once a week.
They have some guy come in here with his Falcon.
To like patrol the campus.
To scare away all the birds and stuff.
From like going around the area.
I thought I was like what?
I didn't realize that was a thing.
And he was like yeah.
Yeah.
They have Falcons.
Like once a week that comes over to the campus at Riot.
and just to like scare away like all the other birds so they
don't have to deal with bird poop
no it's apparently like apparently disney does that too uh
that's why you don't see any like you don't see many like
birds and stuff around disney because like yeah they they do
that at disney as well yeah and then like um other cool
things is that um okay i'll show you guys this i'm sorry I
was going to talk about the concert, but I have to show you
guys this.
I thought this was really funny.
I did not, but I don't, I did not know this, which I, I saw
this, and I was like, why is there a Pepe on the, I don't
know why?
Let's see.
Let me double check.
All right, so what are some things that he told me about?
They tell all of us about.
Oh yeah, there was, they have a little piece.
cbang too a little pc cafe in the studio um and it was
because like for people who are like you know they just want
a game or something like uh like uh like during work hours
or like they want to take a break and start gaming it's what
it's all riot games and then there's battle net it's just
like it's like it's like you know league tft 2x ko um um all
the riot games and then at
Yeah, there's BoundNet at the Riot PC bank.
That was so funny.
There's no other...
It was like, Riot and then BoundNet.
The really classic BoundNet never does.
Let me show you guys...
Okay, I have to show you guys this before I go actually
talking about the content.
And then we'll go back to talking about everything else that
happened.
um anyway so you guys might be wondering what the fuck is
this so you might be wondering what the fuck is this right
here so this is their lp wall so so basically for those who
didn't know because i asked one of my league friends that
they knew about this so if you guys didn't know um if uh
yeah So basically, if you submit a support ticket to ask for
LP, and you can still do this today, by the way, so you can
submit a ticket, support ticket for, and be like, can I have
LP?
And then the support guy will be like, sure, just draw me
something, and then we'll see if you get LP.
If it's a good artwork, they'll give you LP.
So then, at the end of the year, At the end of the year, the
staff, oh, RP, sorry, LRP or is it RP, or sorry, RP, it's
Riot Points.
So at the end of, if you're like missing a couple of points
to rank up, so at the end of the year, a bunch of Riot Staff
will get together and vote for the best artwork that they've
received, and then they'll put it on the wall.
So he's like, I need six points, please.
So you see all these, like, artworks that they displayed.
It's like, please.
And it's for, like, any game.
Is it LP or RP?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Is it for skins?
Does anyone know if it's for skins or rank points?
I thought it was for rank points.
Yeah, so, but it's for any games from Riot.
And so you see Valorant, you see League, you see TFT, it's
for skins.
Okay, so yeah, if you are like, um, um, so if you are
missing points for skins, for skin currency, you can be
granted skin currency if you like draw some art for them.
And I thought I could, I couldn't tell it was for skins or
if it was for rank points.
when he was describing it.
And I thought that was so funny.
So, guys, if you're, like, missing a couple of points for
that newest skin, just submit a little support ticket and
they might grant you some points, guys.
Yeah, it's still around.
They still do it.
Every year, they vote for the best ones to display on the
wall.
and that was fucking hilarious
what are your stuff that I want to tell you guys that they
were telling me it was so interesting like the tour was
really interesting oh yeah they have a keycap wall too let
me show you that this is apparently new so so they have this
new thing called a keycap wall if you're visiting and
basically it's basically that so there's a wall at the
entrance and you can either bring your own keycaps or um
they'll give you kick uh there's like a little keycaps and
some markers guess which one's mine up so um so this is the
keycap wall and you can um exchange a keycap with a riot
keycap um Um, so you basically, you can, they give you
keycaps, and then, or you can bring your own, and, uh, they,
you can exchange it with one of the Riot keycaps up there.
So I have the black one and the red one.
Guess which one's mine?
I also, I got a red one, too, so it's on the other side.
I took a picture of that as well.
Yeah, it's a cap for cap.
I see it.
Do you?
And do you see it?
I wouldn't do which one's mine.
Oh, it is.
Okay.
So, so I thought that one was, I thought that was really
cool.
I mean, there's a lot of stuff.
Like I said, we're planning on getting a official.
Not, well, it was not really, I won't say it.
Can I say it's official?
But we're planning on getting a streamed riot tour with
Jennifer Roberts' husband.
and because I thought it'd be really cool because I don't
want to talk too much about the tour because that he was
such a good tour guy and I want like I was like oh my god
you're so good at this like you should like I feel like I
could not I could not like do you justice you know I cannot
do this justice um I feel like he he's so much more
knowledgeable obviously because he works there so like I
felt like it would be even cooler if like he is the one that
explains everything at the studio because it was very
interesting.
I thought it was really interesting.
Oh yeah, it's really funny.
Okay, I'll give you guys another fun fact.
The studio was originally owned by Lucas Films, apparently.
It was originally owned by Lucas Films before they bought
it.
So there are some buildings that were part of like, you
know, where they screenings for Star Wars and stuff.
And it was so funny because it's like everything around them
and then yeah and then um yeah like star wars yeah and it's
so funny because there's a random fox building uh there's
there's a random fox building that was on the campus and
then he was like yeah that was before riot so we can't
really do anything about it yeah so yeah yeah so there's
like there's like a random fox studio building on canvas
just because like they couldn't do anything because it's
owned by fox so they like they only were able to buy the
surrounding studios around it so so there's just a a random
fox like you know fox broadcast building there on the campus
like yeah uh because they didn't build up they didn't build
this campus.
Well, they built the, they like redecorated, like, you know,
redecorated everything with the, like I said, they, the
courtyard is based off of like, the like League of Legends
maps, like top lane, like mobile map, like top lane, middle
lane, jungle, bottom.
Um, so they refurnished, like, you know, refurnished
everything, but it was so funny that there's just a random
Fox broadcast building next to the courtyard.
Um, man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
hope the concert went well despite a busy la between your
concert i'll start another vtuber eden concert a x july 4 of
250 and more work out thank you the super chat thank you
thank you yeah um give me a sec guys i need to um i need to
pee and also grab some more tissue so i can blow my nose
i'll be right back everybody
i'm back i'm back guys we did it give me a sec let me double
check something real quick because i wonder if they like if
they like saved my version from my laptop because i was like
why where's my dc'd face so i had to like readjust it give
me a sec guys let me look at this real quick everybody just
want to make sure i didn't like save it from my laptop
settings when i was like yes now it works now it works But I
was just like, why didn't it work earlier?
And I'm going to double check my stuff real quick.
Yeah, there's teams, right?
That was weird.
Yeah, it wasn't working early.
I was like, what the fuck is going on?
All right.
Sorry, I had to double check something real quick.
Sorry, I saw like who I was like, oh, what did my...
Who did my mod time out and then I thought it was funny how
He was like but those nerds don't realize because they have
rose tinted glasses You're here too!
You're pride of the nerds!
You're here as well Yeah, just so fucking weird though Yeah,
look in the mirror bro Look, a nerd.
If anything, we're not nerds.
We're talking about sports, bro.
That's like you're one of us.
It's like you're talking about sports.
We're not nerds.
Give me a sec.
Just gotta adjust this real quick.
Yeah, would a nerd talk about sports?
Get in the locker, nerd.
Yeah.
They're in dirt and so confusion.
Um, wait.
Uh, we all live in a locker.
All right, all right.
Now I'll talk about the concert.
Okay.
All right.
One thing I want to bring up about it, which I realized I
didn't talk about before, but birthday concerts end this
year.
It was not supposed to be a reoccurring thing.
It was.
Um, guys, I think I want my, I think I want like a concert
that's not on my birthday.
Oh, but yes, it wasn't supposed to be a reoccurring thing
where it wasn't supposed to be a tradition at all.
It just happened.
It just happened to fall under the same time, like the same
day, um, back to back.
uh like yeah so um if i ever do another concert it will not
be on my birthday because i'm tired of having it on my
birthday i'm tired and for some reason people keep uh
countries and other people keep scheduling for some reason
other other world cup organizations and
doing it on the same day as my birthday and I think that's a
little rude I know why um I was here first um this is my
251st birthday uh so it's not like they planned this um
excuse you um you might be years old uh but i'm 251 so who
came here first the audacity of them so next year i i will
say i will try to make sure this does not happen again
because i i do not want to do another uh i don't want to do
another birthday concert i don't want i honestly because i
feel like it's just a little
like in the articles it's like uh annual tradition i was
like and then i read it i was like wait this is the first
time i heard of that i guess we're ending the tradition this
year
i i guess we're we're ending it this year also another
reason why is that uh just have a contact one of your other
birthdays robin thank you for chatting thank you thank you
um i guess it is just because like uh another thing why i
want to stop doing birthday concerts is because i want to
give you i want to do something else on my birthday you know
i want to do something new on my birthday and also feel bad
because like you know i wasn't able to do a really proper
birthday stream this year just because like i was in l.a and
i was so tired you guys have no idea i was every day i had
to wake up early for something and then um i came home
really late as well So I was like, um, I was always like, I
was so so tired.
I was so like even for this stream I was so tired because I
was like, I slept 17 hours when I finally got home.
I literally Passed out and I think I don't remember what
time I woke up.
I think I woke up like 3 p.m.
Or something three or 4 p.m.
Um, and I just slept the entire day away after I finally got
home because I was so fucking exhausted yeah and um and so
that's like one of the reasons why this will be the last
time I do a bird concert on my birthday just it's just too
much it's it's just a lot and I won't have a I think one
next year I want to have my birth like I want to just
celebrate my birthday with you guys um like at home I don't
I don't want to travel anywhere on my birthday at home with
you guys yeah for next year so the tradition ends ends this
year it wasn't supposed to be a tradition it was just a
coincidence that was back to back but it ends this year
oh yeah i forgot to show you guys the birthday cake sadly um
sadly i didn't eat much of the birthday cake like i said um
it was so sad because it didn't fit the fridge because it
was too this was the birthday cake this was the birthday
cake that they used at the dokey dokey rewind time
unfortunately in that this cake I didn't eat a lot of the
cake I only ate like the corner of chibi dokey's feet like
right there no no they forgot to cut the cake for everybody
um so it was just me and I had no utensils I mean you guys
were there live when it's the one where I sort of destroyed
my hands and then it didn't fit the fridge because like I
said it was a big it was like a rectangular cake and the
fridge is a square so it didn't fit the fridge so um I just
left it on the table yeah that was too tight room service
was closed and I was so tired um next Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Glad to hear now a perfect and unbeatable record on
attending Doki's birthday concerts.
Two out of two!
Next, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, the room's due, it's no room service.
So, I just tanked it.
Um, hey, let's get a slice of that virtually holographic.
Many, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I was so tired, too.
I didn't want to go downstairs to the lobby.
um to like uh to like grab a fourth or something oh yes okay
this is what i want to show you guys i'll show you guys
behind the scenes stuff now um so you guys didn't know um
sachi is a whale and that was her choice uh she want i asked
her like oh what do you want to be do you want to be like do
you want like have like a because i was i was like i was
down to like pay for and everything too um just because like
you know I really appreciate her being a part of the concert
and I was like oh you want me I'll pay for the model and she
was like oh we can just be the whale that I used during um
that was used during uh Mimi's concert so uh shout out to
Mimi for letting me uh borrow um the uh the whale model and
then I paid for the reskin of it basically so and let me see
if I let me see oh so this was sachi's concept art of the
whale yeah let me show you guys so because like she wanted
to um she wanted to like use the whale uh model for the
concert and this was her concept her so she wanted um she's
like i want the flower to be like wilting so she sent me
this shout out to our 3d modeler for for getting taking that
and coming up with where is it let me let me grab like the
so this was the inspiration and then And here was the, like,
it was them, us, like, playing around with it.
So we're in different colors and everything.
So this is the original.
Yeah, nailed it.
And then we were like, oh, we should have a spike collar.
Because obviously, you know, obviously it's like a emo goff
well.
So then after that, we went with...
this so we add and then we're like oh you should be angrier
so we went from this to to let you know the emo goff well
yeah uh hang on thank you the super chat thank you thank you
so yeah so that's how the the sachi will came to be and
stuff uh so you know how like what's his name the guy in the
boys who's the cube so the the motion capture was sort of
like that where by the way originally for the motion capture
the whale was supposed to be sort of moving around but i
think like it i think it makes sense so yeah they were like
jack quaid yeah jack quaid you know if you guys ever seen
the Jack Wade motion capture it was sort of similar but like
it's not a cube it was it wasn't a cube but it was like sort
of similar and like originally she was supposed to be like
moving around the stage I think that was like I think it
looked a little too weird so that's why she was in place
because I think I was like I was like bumping I was like
clipping into her Yeah, I was clipping into her because she
was originally moving around the stage sort of I think I was
clipping into her So we had to change the plan and So it was
just me moving around her Yeah, because it was supposed to
leave her in the center and then me like the choreo was
supposed to be She was in the center and I was supposed to
be Moving around her But I think because like it just looked
a little bit too like it just i was clipping into her too
much um we put her to the side instead because she was
originally in the center yeah um was oh yeah by the way guys
for those who don't know the uh feel good is fixed now in
streaming tickets so if you guys want to you know if you
guys bought streaming tickets or anything uh link is pinned
in my chat or you can use the qr code um you have a photo
after you done no unfortunately I forgot to take a picture
of that I wish I did Gordon thank you the super chat thank
you thank you um but yes uh feel good is now fixed uh on
streaming tickets so you guys want to buy streaming tickets
already um and you want to check out the uh um check it out
uh you can um uh you can buy the tickets or pull up from the
tickets you already bought and watch it again yeah i'll post
the link yet also we still have our merch store open as well
so for the uh doki doki rewind time merch so you guys
haven't got the doki doki rewind time merch um pre-orders
are still out i don't know when pre-orders are ending um oh
um they haven't told me when pre-orders are ending but i can
ask them later on to find out for us um and also there's a
bunch of little hot fixes as well to the um to the the
streaming tickets as well um but i do i'm writing i'm
currently working on um on a notes for them on stuff i want
to change and tweak um but they just did this for hot fixes
so um this is just for hot fixes so uh so what they could
fix send put out right now
um yeah they removed the i was the rewind time no the
cursor's gone too yeah uh canada and mexico might be out but
surely doki can now root for fans to go all the way that's
where daft punk are from after all and yes this is me asking
doki for more world cup watchalongs maybe a super chat carl
thank you thank you yeah i'm planning on doing the last
final games so the semis uh the semis quarters and finals uh
because we're already there and i already paid for my
subscription on Crave before I have to like fucking cancel
it so so I might as well go all the way to the end I already
paid my Crave subscription so I'm paying it off I think for
this the reason why I didn't watch France versus Morocco
because I knew it wasn't I'm sorry but like statistically I
was looking at statistics wise I knew like you know embape
like statistically I knew like France was the stronger team.
So I was thinking, like, I don't think it might be, like, me
personally, I was like, I don't think this would be like,
our guys already sat through, like, I'm sorry, Switchblade,
I already sat through so much Haramball to, like, the last
two days.
Yeah, so I was just thinking, yeah, I was like, I was
watching the first half of the game.
um i was watching the first half of the game with friends
versus morocco and and i was just like oh my god like i'm
i'm it's i'm so bored i'm so sorry the first half of that
game was not that exciting
yeah so i was just like oh man
I was like, oh man, I just didn't think I should do a watch
along because I felt like, I don't know.
I think like, I feel like, uh, I had a feeling that the game
won't be like extremely exciting to watch.
So that's why I didn't do a watch along today for it.
But we are doing the, I feel like Norway versus England is
going to be exciting as well as Argentina versus
Switzerland.
Only because of my pure hatred for Switzerland.
I'm sorry for everybody who's Switzerland, who are Swiss.
Yeah, I'm so sorry for all my Swiss followers.
It's not you.
It's your team.
I'm sorry.
Jeez.
Like the slits.
It's okay.
They're neutral.
All your neutrality didn't.
nothing.
It's not me either.
It's not me.
It's not you.
It's Harambaugh.
It's the meta.
Look, you guys knock Canada off of home turf, okay?
It's reasonable.
Guys, look, my hate is justified.
Canada could have been playing in Canada.
Kachigo, thank you for this to reach out.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, what was I going to say?
What was I talking about before?
Um, yeah, you are not forgiven.
Yeah.
Um, what was I talking about before?
It was about the concert.
Uh, oh yeah.
there are hot fixes with the concert vibe but i'm currently
after the stream i'm going to finish my notes because i have
to re-watch the entire streaming tickets i didn't watch um
i'm watching the streaming tickets and then writing the
notes of everything i want changing want to change which
includes like camera angles and everything so um um so i'm
uh uh after the stream um i'll be working on that um and
okay i i this was something i wanted i forgot to mention
about too um um uh but um this was the first time i had
technically no input for the 3d stuff in terms of like i
didn't even know what it's gonna look like literally the
first gonna look like was like I guess like after the
concert after slash during the concert because like um all
that was handled by uh fantastic reality including like the
the studio they were working with so I know no communication
regarding the uh regarding like uh uh so I was obviously I
was very scared i was very nervous about it because i didn't
know what it was gonna what it was gonna look like you know
i was so anxious and stressed out yeah so i had no like i
didn't have control over um over like what it would look
like overall in terms of like the stage or um what the
camera because like before all the other kind of sponsors
i've done um i had like especially like the one I did last
year.
I had full control over everything, like camera angles, what
I wanted the camera angles to look like, what I wanted the
stage to look like, how I wanted the, the, the shaders and
everything.
Like, so this was the first time that I didn't know what it
was going to look like there.
Um, and it was more so like, I think it was also because we
were such a tight deadline that they didn't uh uh that uh um
because of course I would I want to see what it looks like
you know of course like I would want to see what it would
look like before the concert but because timing was so tight
and everything um they weren't able to show me uh anything
at that time so like when I during so I didn't know like uh
so that's why like I'm I have like a I'm doing like full
notes on like what I want to change because obviously I'm a
perfectionist you know um I'm a perfectionist so obviously
you know I love I want to make it the best as it could be so
there is going to be another edit of the vibe um with like
my notes in it of like what I would like to change and
everything because it's like if they're like uh and they
were I think they were also worried if they showed me I
would be like I want to change everything which I would do
that not gonna lie But they'd be like, Toki, there's no
time.
But I was like, it's too bad.
Yeah, I feel like that would have happened.
That would have happened.
They showed it to me.
Yeah.
I'd be like, no.
Cheek, fix this.
Yeah, it was, it was, I was so stressed out.
Too bad.
So, uh, change, there's still time, don't worry, we still
have 24 hours, there's still time to make these changes,
yeah, so, um, it was a good choice on their end, because I
would have absolutely been like, change, I would have been
like, stop the concert, stop the delay, stop the concert, We
got to have changed this.
So yeah.
Yeah, so I didn't see the test footage at all until like
during and after the concert.
So that's why like we're doing it.
We're having another round of edits.
This time they're not hot fixes.
But I'm planning on like, you know, I have like basically I
have timestamps where I was like boot to like Like this time
stamp to this time stamp change it to this camera angle this
time stamp to this time stamp change it to this camera angle
Change fix this part here Swap this to this close up swap it
to this POV of the band maybe like I it's basically really
detailed notes because like like I said I'm very I'm a huge
perfectionist.
I like I want to have like the yeah, I'm giving a I'm
sitting I'm writing a patch note right now
I'm writing a fucking patch note for the newest release of
the VOD.
So I'm going to be working on that after the stream.
And I really appreciate you guys' participation.
Yeah, the Doki cut, basically.
The director's cut, which is me, the D-cut.
The Doki cut.
But we did hot fix it.
We hot fixed with some changes to some camera angles in the
concert, as well as fixing the slouchy part.
uh and we are planning on like i said we're planning on
uploading uh two videos uh from the concert which would be
99 red balloons and feel good so uh um so look forward to
that uh those two i don't know when they'll be released uh
my new oshidoki scorsese thank you super chat papa smirk
thank you thank you um sapphire thank you super chat thank
you thank you yo glad to have you back from LA.
It looked like the concert went amazing.
Love your song choices and your singing has gotten even
better.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate it.
I told you guys the set list was my most proud
accomplishment in the concert.
I felt like I crafted the perfect set list for this theme.
Despite many difficulties finalizing the set list because we
didn't get like there was other songs I was supposed to be
but we just didn't get perms and stuff.
I'm just happy with how, like, where we ended off with the
set list despite the difficulties getting some of the perms
I wanted.
Like, you know, some songs got cut just because I couldn't
get the perms and stuff.
So I'm happy with what we ended up on in the end because I
felt like it was just the perfect set list for the theme.
And I was very particular about the set list too.
Like, I wanted it to be a perfect set list.
for the concert and yeah like everything uh you know thank
you guys so much for uh the support for the concert too um
like i said like i want the people who are watching not from
like from home or like not at the venue to also have a great
experience watching the streaming tickets as well so that's
why like um after the stream i'm sending my i'm finishing my
notes for it so that we can the experience a lot more for
the people who are watching at home as well because like I
the one thing that I was I'm changing one thing I'm changing
is I wanted more camera angles of the choreo more because I
noticed this is the one things I noticed was that because I
like I said I didn't know what the streaming tickets look
like it's so different from live for those who are watching
live versus streaming tickets because when you're watching a
live at the venue you get to see everything you know you get
to see the people in the middle like you see like the full
body and also the close-ups as well both at the same time
but uh i noticed that after i finally was able to see
streaming tickets that it was different for you guys where
there was not a lot of uh there was a lot of crowd shots
like that's one of my notes i wrote too i was like um let's
focus on the crowd shots and more on the choreo um and then
um yes i also wanted more shots of the fortnite damn emo
sounds doing uh yeah wait dad that's one of the notes i
wrote as well there are too many crowd shots so that's why
um that's why i'm trying to make sure the offline experience
for those who weren't there at the venue get to experience
um get to have better experience as well as well the concert
itself so um that's why i was like very uh i was very I'll
have you guys know right now is very stressed out
post-concert because I realized what the streaming tickets
were like the streaming tickets and stuff and I was like
obviously I always want to I'm such a perfectionist so I was
like this could be better you know so I was so I was so
stressed out about it because obviously I was like this
could be better and I was such a perfectionist being like oh
my god like oh even during the concert I was so stressed out
because all the rewind time moments you guys have no idea
okay so i'll show you i'm gonna show you guys this so uh i'm
glad you guys still had a great time i know i'm i i always
just want to get give you guys the the best experience
possible yeah and uh and i always you know i always want to
give you guys the the best you can get and oh yeah but the
pre-show where i played apex so yes that one was it a lot so
so i had to pre-record the pre-show um because there was no
way for me to commentate it um we tried to make it so i
could commentate it live but we couldn't we there was we
couldn't set it up uh it was just like logistically wise it
was like too much work so uh it's don't worry Because I'm
going to play the video of the pre-show.
Because it got, there were technical difficulties on the
pre-show.
And I was, you guys had no idea how stressed out I was.
Because half the pre-show was cut out.
And I was like, that's when I was fracking out.
So I was showing.
a little bit of a background knowledge getting the getting
this pre-show recorded let me tell you this took me and the
other dokey bird and the dad two days to pre-record because
we were so watched and we tried to get a good game to show
at the concert just for it to be cut in half because of
technical difficulties.
I was so mad.
On day one of it, we played Apex Legends for five hours
straight.
We played Apex for five fucking hours straight.
Trying to get a good game to show for at the concert and
then like we got like the thing is we won like two games one
to two to three games but they were all shit like they were
all like bad wins in a way we're like in a way we're like we
fight one to two teams and then it was over like it was just
that bad so so i was just like our best game was when we got
second place because we were constantly non-stop fighting
like we fought Then we got second place in the end and I was
so mad because it was such a it was a really good game And I
was like yeah clip farm we were trying to get we were trying
to clip farm and then so then we were Like let's do this
another day because maybe like maybe it was just not a good
day of apex And then like the second day we booted it up and
we got the win on our second try And I was like oh my god
and then I was like so excited I was like oh man I cannot
wait this show this game to my to my um to the dragoons and
my concert and then and then and they got cut in half they
skipped like two fights and they got rewind time three times
and i was so i was so I will say I was mad
I spent like seven hours trying to get this pre-show done
and I was so mad I was like rewind time three times rewind
time so I will show the entirety of my pre-recorded pre-show
right here Right now, without any scuff.
At least we'll have it somewhere, you know?
All right, let me see it.
All right.
Sayonara for a little bit, guys.
You're gonna watch this.
You guys better watch this.
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Doki.
Doki, doki, rewind time!
Oh my god, are you ready, dragons?
For the moment you've all been waiting for?
Get ready, drum roll please!
For!
Concerts canceled, I'm playing Apex Legends.
That's right!
We are back!
Guys, a supernatural concert, we're gonna be watching me
play a video game!
Yeah!
That's right, this time, so Marvel Rivals, we're going back
to our roots, Apex Legends.
And I brought on my squad, Dad, and Doki Bird.
That's right, we got a Doki from the Doki Birds joining in.
But which one is the real Doki Bird?
uh yeah so as you guys can see uh dad is a sweaty uh bald
raf right now i don't even know if he's actually bald right
i can't i don't remember yeah there you go you guys see that
okay um i punched there because it's been a while so i was
just like how do i to swap my weapon so i have like weird
ass uh fucking keybinds um so uh my main like my push to
talk is actually my weapon swap to talk to anybody because
I'll be on discord with my squad so there's no randoms to
talk to so that's why I was just like punching midair I
think like for here we are contesting a squad here I'm
pretty sure yes we wow you guys didn't notice well of course
two jokies are playing support characters and that's the DPS
we are heavily relying on dad to carry us right now If we
all pump as much resources into our bald sweaty rave main,
surely he'll get a kill.
Right, guys?
All right, as you guys see, there is that one team we're
contesting.
And I'm just like, where the fuck is he?
And then I'm like, oh, my kill.
That's right, kill's still here.
And then, as you guys can see, it's been a while.
I could have pulled up my R9.
Instead of, I don't fucking know, aiming down sight with my
fucking long-range hemlock gun.
But I wasn't, I just, I wasn't thinking clearly, okay?
I was just like, whatever.
And I was like, you know what?
Let me pump up my damage.
Oh yeah, there's one more guy here.
And then I was just like, there's three of us and one of
him.
I'll sacrifice myself.
And then I was like, okay, res me, doki.
We have the numbers.
So I was just like, fucking Yolo.
We're going back in.
I'll just get as much damage as I could and then I'll put
and get res and I'll come back um but here we go there was
one more guy I think we couldn't find him from what I
remembered uh and so I was just like fuck it let's just
let's just go if we res if they res him we'll just kill him
again um but yeah anyway just walking around being like I
think oh yeah I remember this some shit.
I was just like, where is he?
I think I saw him.
He's right here, right?
And I was like seeing things, but then I was like, oh, he's,
no.
I think I was just being schizo, I think.
And then I was just like, fuck it.
Let's just go.
Let's just fight.
Like, please, we go.
Go, go, go.
Fight, fight, fight.
I hear gunshots.
Let's fucking go over there and kill them.
Who cares about this one guy?
I just want to kill.
I want to shoot things.
Um, okay, I lied.
This might not have been the only were this might not have
been the first game this might have been like the the best
game we recorded me dad and Tokyo we were we were sort of in
the trenches oh wow we might all be washed by the way we
gathered like a bunch we were like I love you guys played
Apex they're like oh all right and then we first we did a
couple of pubs and then um we had two what are games we won,
but they were so bad.
And they were like, we won the game, but it was just like,
you know, it was like, it didn't feel like we won.
Like, I think it was like one of the games recorded.
It was like, um, we killed one team and then there was 10
squads left.
And I was just like, bro, let's come back in two days.
And then maybe we had a session where we played for like,
okay, Like we had a time where we played like I think for
like four hours straight.
Trying to get like one win.
That's all like and then we got like three.
But they were all so trashed.
Like I didn't we didn't feel like winners.
Like our best game was when we were second place.
Because we were like constantly fighting.
And then but then like we got second.
I was like we can't show second place guys.
We're winners guys.
We're winners in the dokeverse.
place game even though it was like literally our best game
we're like okay then we're like all right we're gonna come
back like in two days and then maybe when we're like we're
like refreshed and also i'm in eu one of one of doki's is in
eu so uh yeah and in one of the doki versus uh doki is
european so as you guys can see uh that's why i have almost
200 pings by the way i don't you guys might not be seeing
the text is really real the ping counter is like oh yeah dad
yelled let me hear you he was like he's like not don't don't
look at the door and look at the other side where they come
he's like he's like fork fork fork look at the other fucking
side oh but yeah you guys might not be the text is very the
numbers are very tight but look at look at who we go i'm so
fucking smart i was just like all right they won't expect me
on the other side and also i like altered the door because
they won't i don't know why they fucked me like are you
fucking stupid or some shit like yay i won with yay i won by
doing nothing well i did do something i altered the door it
was all strategies guys um but yeah it uh we had like four
hours of footage recorded on one day but like it was just
four hours of trash we like swapped from pumps to wildcard
because we're like we need more action and then like when we
when we got more action we So they were like, okay, we need
action, but also we need a lift.
I just think it was a bad day to play Apex that day.
So then we came back.
This is when we came back two days later.
And then we finished, we got like a win within our, this was
our third game.
And we got a win.
Like we almost got a win on our first game.
But it was a really, we got like, for some fucking reason, a
team like landed on us for no reason during the last three
squads.
we were like outside of zone and they landed on us and we're
like what are you doing like and then they died in zone and
i was like i it was off stream dokey so i was just like
i thought i thought i'd be freed in one game let's just say
like
anyway um we're just trying to rotate here oh there you go
Bork, Bork, there's Dad.
He just wants the fight.
Bork, Bork, Bork.
And then there's European Doki.
Being like, do you want a 3X?
I'm like, no, it's cool.
No.
Sadly, European Doki and Dad aren't here to commentate with
me.
So it's just you and I, dragons.
Guys enjoying the gameplay?
Yeah?
Alright, then I guess we'll do another one.
That's the end.
entire concert guys is you can't leave the doors closed like
we've locked the doors we're gonna keep going we're gonna
get let's get let's get Fred guys let's get apex predator
today everyone oh yeah and then this last guy was just like
fuck it if I die you can res me that was my time maybe I
should stop playing like that also dad was just like maybe
you just stop playing support if you're just gonna throw
yourself into the fight and i was like no this is oh wait no
this is a game where i was supposed to play pathfinder by
the way but i forgot to click pathfinder because we're
because like dad and your fiyu doki was like can you like if
you're just gonna run at people can you like at least play a
character that has mobility and i was like okay i guess i'll
try but then obviously i forgot to like it's because there
was another dokey bird in hero select so i thought for some
reason i thought i was last pick but i was actually second
pick because i got confused i was like which dokey bird is
dokey bird one and oh this was me being a little silly i was
like you know what i'm gonna fly i wanted to fly to like uh
to an off angle but um it didn't really work so it was a
little silly i I have to admit, I might have wasted my
little redeploy because I thought I could stand up here for
some fucking reason.
And I was just like, okay, well, I'm coming back, guys.
Because I saw a team over there.
So I was like, oh, I'll sit on high ground.
And for some reason, my tiny brain was just like, I can
stand there.
But it's last three squads.
And we were like, let's just, I don't know why.
was bloodthirsty and he was like i want to fight the team in
the house i was like his last two squads like should we like
wait a little bit until they we third party like little rest
but like whatever all right let's just do it maybe we'll
kill them fast even though they're they are the other team
is waiting for us so it just means mating with the little
nades because they they did i did kill the watch and all and
then oh yeah they got the fucking bat too i would have
killed that guy get the bat instantly and then i saw the
team read a point i was like we gotta leave bro guys just
leave i'll say i don't know i i maybe i was being a little
pussy but i didn't want to get third party because i'm like
this could be the game guys this so i was just like i'm just
gonna run and uh i thought like maybe the other the other
guy was also gonna run but for some reason he also wanted to
keep the other team solo also wanted to keep fighting um so
um i was just like i was just like i'm gonna go res i was
gonna res european doki um i was like just they're they're
because like i saw them running away so i was just like just
just leave because they're they're planning on going like i
don't know why they're planning to just leave us alone i was
like just stay in zone and then I'm gonna go res uh eudoki
and then and then uh there was a little miscommunication so
I was like I'm gonna craft him and I'm gonna craft her and
I'm gonna res her uh oh and then and then he got knocked the
moment I crafted and then dad was like what why did you not
wait and I was like what do you mean I said hide typical dad
not listening to me so then I was just like alright you
dokey you go craft dad and then I'll rest dad on the other
rest beacon and dad was like I told you to wait for me to
die and I was like well I told you to hide it's not My fault
that you didn't hide.
All right, here we go.
Now I'm going to go rest the other.
You see, my strat worked, guys.
Sometimes, sometimes it's strategic to run away, guys.
I bravely ran away so I could get my teammates back who have
no attachments, no big meds or anything.
But there's a reason why.
This team is shown in the concert
There's a reason why All right, and then here goes I see the
other for some reason the other team did not chase us They I
mean, I don't know why they fucking went to zone They could
have easily like just killed me.
I was just I was just pressing I don't know why they just
fucking decided to go to zone, but they're just up there and
then me the fully-kitted conduit was like you go in first uh
oh yeah and i also didn't lose any big men's i don't know
i'm just a little special uh but yeah but here is the final
fight it's the final countdown
oh so by the way this this is not being streamed online so
you guys get the concert exclusive
so this is a concert exclusive by the way if you guys are
phone you get phone records okay it'll be funny i was by the
way you can post this part online if you want to uh and
you're recording that your phone recording does you can post
this online okay i say when the match is about to end also
right here i got a call from my uber eats so this is this
look this is when i got a call from my uber eats and i was
just like oh shit i guess because my food was here and i was
like i answered the call I but we did it we won I was like I
answer calls let them in and I was like all right now I VM
here you go got my food let's go got my food and I won
yeah we're champions now uh but yeah I like how I say at the
end I was like by the way you can record this part because
it's not being streamed but it was like at the final fight
all right that was it that was that's right i posted it
online that's right spoiler it was me who leaked it on the
stream
yeah that that was our best game that that was our best game
What's if that was so guys look look half of that wasn't
even in the concert guys come on half of this was me I did I
leaked exclusive content and dokey came dokey the permission
to post it online how can dokey dokey the only reason why it
wasn't on streaming tickets is because of permission.
Because, like, the spawn, we had to sign a contract with
Apex and we wanted to put it in streaming tickets.
And, like, there was no time.
Because we had this idea.
The idea to do this was already, like, really late into the
prep.
So, like, there was no way we could get permission from Apex
Legends in time to put it in streaming tickets.
So...
because like spot is a jap if you guys didn't know spot is a
japanese website so they need like explicit perms from the
devs to include it in the streaming tickets and that's why
we couldn't have the pre-show in streaming tickets because i
was playing apex legends so so that was our best game I
could finally show you guys in the full recording.
It wasn't even, okay, to be fair, to be fair, to be fair.
To be fair, it might have been last minute idea, but it was
a good last minute idea.
It was unfortunate that we had, the thing is, at least the
technical difficulties hit the pre-show.
instead of the actual concert the pre-show was the tech test
at least guys yeah yeah at least the pre-show tanked it all
take the majority of it yeah yeah but it only it only hit a
imagine if we didn't have the pre-show and it hit it hit the
actual concert portion yeah the real it did yeah uh
instructions unclear fuck it will you ball rebut thank you
super chat thank you thank you um but yeah so there that was
the pre-show you guys at least like now you get to see it in
full in full glory without the missing footage because like
when they cut it it was like when there was like the rewind
time moment and then like the difficulties there were some
context missing because there was some context missing so
I'm glad you were able to like now I get to show you guys
the full context of the it's like you guys were all there
exactly it's like we're here watching it live yeah now the
show can start what else I want to talk about for I had,
like, stuff written down.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah.
Anime Expo.
I'm sorry, but definitely one of the...
Art of Salty was not it.
Everything else.
For those who...
I got FOMO for Anime Expo.
Do not worry.
I went through...
I braved the hall...
I braved...
Okay, everything else.
The other halls were fine.
like uh the exhibitor stuff a-okay artist alley was like a
fucking war zone i felt like i was in no man's land um
artist alley like it was like it's like a line but like you
have to like it's like you're driving a car in artist alley
and um and then if you want to you have to do to a turn
signal if you see something you like in the line and like
you're like literally like queued up in a fucking line in a
car lane or some shit and then but it's like you're in the
middle of the lane so on the right and left are the artist
alley booths i didn't want to go into the artist alley booth
lane because um because uh because like you know i don't
know if i don't want it's like such a slow lane too the lane
is so slow if you go to the artist alley lane but then like
there's the middle lane and then the left lane and then the
right lane and the left and right lane are so slow so and it
was very very crowded and like people were actually having
attacks in the lane like because they were claustrophobic
and like people were having like claustrophobic panic
attacks like i've counted like three different people
they're having their own miniature panic attack while in the
lane and i'm like oh my god i've been to a lot of
conventions and like i've never had this experience before
where like yeah you're in the freeway and you're they're
like on a it's like la traffic jam basically like usually
i've been to so many the artist alley this is the worst i've
ever this is the worst i've ever like encountered when it
comes to like an artist alley like i literally checked out i
was like i'm out i'm i went i went through all the lanes one
time did a quick skim through i was also so fucking sad my
weiner dog diner hoodie was sold out and also discontinued
on the day my card was finally fixed anyway it was I
literally went through all the lanes and I tapped out.
I couldn't do this.
Like, I legitimately did not.
I don't even want to fucking look through it any closer.
Because apparently Sunday was really, really bad.
It was so fucking bad.
It was so crowded.
And it was more crowded than Saturday and Friday.
It was just a lot worse.
It was like a war zone.
But the exhibit was fine.
Did you guys know what I found out?
So if you're an exhibitor, if you're an exhibitor, rent a
space an exhibitor because I asked my staff about it because
I was like oh my because like she was she's like she's done
a lot of events before so she was telling me like I was like
how much is it to rent she was like oh these are not cheap
to rent by the way because like because we're talking about
like spaces like if you're at the front it's more expensive
obviously if you want the front like the what's the word
there's a word for it but um for like the hot zones you know
like yeah like it's the if you want the hot zones it's very
expensive but like obviously further back up the more the
cheaper it is it's just telling me the ones that are like
front to middle is a hundred k to rent the space for
exhibitors i was like so i was like oh 10k it's a hundred k
it's so it's like oh it's 10k right that's expensive no it's
a hundred k to rent and exhibit like to to have to rent an
exhibitor space at the front like at the front to middle
yeah and then it's apparently if you want like those like
you know how like some exhibitors some exhibitor displays
are like super fancy um and like are are like like really
decorative and everything or like you know like big or
something it's another 100k like some some exhibitors spent
around 200k for both for a booth set like the decorations
and everything and the rent space itself yeah that's how
much that's how much they charge and adam i was just like oh
my god i like i would never afford that i was just like i
could i could technically if i was like um i could
technically because it's like more about like p like like
for the like you might be like that's way too expensive but
the amount of publicity you can get from that is crazy
because you can people can stream it you know people can
take pictures of it stream it you guys see like love and
deep space like the amount of free publicity they got just
from there just from their dating sim bouff yeah yeah it's
marketing is good mark like it's like do you know how much
publicity they got from there yeah from there from the
interactive interaction thing yeah the cosplayers um my my
staff member uh so um i met some of the nom's cafe staff
people too and one of them is a hardcore love and deep space
uh um player and she got one of the yeah the lads the
producer don't know it's literally they I don't even know if
I could put a picture of it.
Let me see.
Let me see my phone if I have.
So one of them actually won the lottery.
Won the lottery to see, like, I don't know, his name, Silas,
or whatever.
Oh, my God.
I just, she talked a lot about this guy.
Jay.
That, I had, like, Korean barbecue with a bunch of people.
And, like, she was, like, playing.
she was playing lads during Korean barbecue too um I think
her name his name is I don't know Silas or whatever I'm
sorry I don't play lads I'm so sorry for anyone offended I
don't play lads so I have no idea about anything related to
lads uh trying to say I can I don't have a photo of it but
she said she showed me a lot of videos and photos just so
you guys know um I saw a lot of of uh of the lat oh wait no
my my event staff sent me some photos too let me grab it she
sent me some too because she's like she was like waiting in
line with her um apparently people were like coming in with
wedding dresses um okay so because i was curious i was
curious about the whole lads thing like um like because it's
for those who don't know it's a game because they were I
don't understand.
I don't get it, obviously, because I was like, you know, I
don't play gotcha games.
So, like, I don't get it.
You know?
So, um, it's, it's basically a, uh, gotcha visual novel
otome game made by women for women.
So this is like one of the few gotcha games slash otomo
games that, uh, are made by women.
So they know what women want, you know?
So they know what the triggers are.
you know so like they crack the system they like crack the
formula because they are also women so they know so they
were educating me about about lives love and d space and uh
yeah five women four women yeah so um so i was like i was
curious as you know i was getting educated because like um
the the sap member she's played a lot of lads like she's
like she won the lottery for it too um and um so let me see
let me see i could find it so apparently they're like actors
as well i believe uh let me see let me see i can find our
group chat where she sent me
I'm trying to find the chat where she sent me like a I don't
even know we have so many chats I don't even know which one
is the which one is the main one where she sent me stuff she
deleted all the oh my god it'd be funny if she did I think
she did I don't see it anymore Wait, let me see.
When was the...
Oh,
there it is.
She didn't delete all of it.
No, there it is.
I had to scroll.
Alright.
Let me see if I can find the video.
She didn't delete it.
I just couldn't... I just didn't scroll up and tap.
Oh,
yeah, I did not go to the midnight mahjong for those who
want to know I did not go My staff highly recommended me not
to go and they were sort of right
They're like you mean you should not go to you should not do
it
Let's see because like they don't even play mahjong anymore
like It was basically, it was like ParkCon, but they brought
it to Midnight Majan.
Apparently, they don't even play Midnight Majan anymore.
What's the point?
What's the point of Midnight Majan if there's no Midnight
Majan?
That defeats the whole purpose of Midnight Majan.
Wait, there was Majan?
Where was it?
I didn't, I couldn't, apparently they couldn't find where it
was.
Please play Majan with me.
I've never, I've never played Majan before.
by the way.
Daddy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's one, it was 2 a.m.
Mahjong.
That defeats the whole purpose.
Why isn't it at midnight?
I watch, oh, you watch Rice and Daddy playing Mahjong for
hours.
But was it at midnight?
Next seat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But was it at midnight?
oh here we go here we go i won't post this video but this is
basically this was basically what you got when you're there
this was oh yeah and then um so yeah for those who are like
what is that that's the uh that's that's the lads so like
when you're there you get to be yeah I don't know how much
how else I could describe it I there was it was next to this
it was next to the juice so basically let me explain all
right don't worry I have videos of this okay not this part
but like I gotta send a video so let me explain so oh my
gosh that so um so each of the boys in lads they they have a
little meet and greet basically interactive meeting greet
where you get to interact with each of the lad boys and um
they're they're like in character and everything too so
there was a lot of instances there were a lot of viral
moments that came from so you guys were like that's so
expensive because you know i said like marketing was like
like you know to rent a booth is like a hundred k but this
was like i feel like it like paid itself in a way where uh
where you know there were so many videos and viral moments
of the lad boys of the interactions that they had with the
lads.
Yeah.
So, like, some people came in, like, wedding dresses, some,
like, some straddled.
I'm sorry.
I'm trying to say this with, like, trying to say, describe
this.
But like, they're all professionally trained cosplayers from
China.
So they brought them, they're, like, professional.
actors slash cosplayers from China that they brought to
anime expo so they got trained for this and everything and
um yeah so but then like like I said uh wow okay like I said
there's like a lot of clips from from the lads and I was
curious too you know I was just like oh um I was very
curious on.
Oh, so here's more.
Yeah.
Oh, and poor didn't find China.
So I was curious because like, how did the lottery work?
So, um, so basically it was like what?
They drew, uh, they drew like the names for people.
So you have to have an account, obviously, to sign up for
the lottery.
And like, you have to draw.
um you have to like get drawn from the lottery but they they
get chosen on around the end of june so i think it was like
june 30th or something yeah uh june 30th was when they draw
the names and i was and then i was so curious i was like you
must be able to scalp that you know but then um the staff
member who was a lad's lad player like she was the lad's
enjoyer she was like no no it's link to your account and I
was like well you can just sign in to the account like
there's no way that shit did not get scalped you know
because I was just like because I was saying like what if
you know people already bought tickets to like you know
anime expo and everything you know so like and like they
already bought tickets to anime expo they already got their
flights and hotel they're gonna see them no matter what you
know so I was like because like there I felt like there must
be a they must have like you could you could literally like
sell your account info with yeah there's no way if i like if
i invested that much to see the lads at lads like
i mean bro like got the flights the tickets everything they
will see them no matter what it doesn't matter how yeah yeah
all they need is account information right so you can just
sign into like your you can sign into your account like I
was like there's no way this person pre because like like
some of them brought wedding dresses right yeah some of them
brought wedding dresses I was like they knew no matter what
they're gonna see them they're gonna see the lads no matter
what if I bring a wedding dress like I will make sure I see
them like yeah yeah because she said um because she was
telling me how they only check the account info they don't
check id or anything yeah so i was just like oh that's easy
then you literally just you just log into your friends like
that you have get a bunch of your friends get a bunch of
your friends to get drafted in the lottery and then yeah and
then and then like one of them one of you guys lottery one
of you guys will win the lottery you sign it in their
account yeah
because the lottery was drafted at june 30th so there's not
enough time the convention started at july what july 2nd or
july 1st there's no there's not like you it's like risky at
all oh yeah apparently there was the parting of the sea so
uh for those who didn't know uh and a btuber fans are very
social next thing thank you super chat thank you thank you
and also um so they were gonna when they left so you see
like there was a the part like they made like a everybody
waited at the waited at the exhibit hall for the lads to
leave so and then they made a parting of the sea so they
have a pathway to leave and then and then they found out
they were at the other side they exited a different side of
the building i felt so bad like there's apparently there was
like a lot of people just waiting there for them to come out
and then they left the different exit
that's so awkward you know that's like you the 50 50 like
it's like they lost the gotcha i was like oh man I would be
so sad if that happened if I waited because you know you
have to wait like what one to two hours yeah you have to
wait one to two hours and then you lost the gotcha and they
went the other exit like oh my god no there was still no it
was both exits both exits had like exits had like a bunch of
people but it was literally just the 50 50 it was like a 50
50 on which exit they're gonna be so yeah like the coin flip
failed yeah pretty good odds though pretty good odds
honestly but that's that's the lad that's that's the lads
yeah both exits both exits had a bunch of people
Someone, yeah, someone the 50-50.
I think the Lads booth was definitely the most successful
booth out of Anime Expo.
There was always, like, a lot of people there.
Like, consistently.
Because it's, like, a lot.
Like, you know, everybody is there to meet the Lads.
So I think, like, I felt like I saw a lot about them during
the Twitter for my...
I saw a lot about them during Twitter.
It's a smart...
It's very smart marketing.
I will say.
Yeah.
It's definitely very smart marketing.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I did not realize...
Well, I knew you guys were going to love the new 3D outfit.
I didn't realize how much you...
How much you guys would love it.
A little fun fact.
The 3D outfit was made in a month, including the design.
fun fact guys that because like everything was on such a
tight deadline so we had to get everything done in a month
so shout out to the artist and the 3d modeler it took like
around a month to get everything done like including
concepts um including concept to to model itself do i have
it here I did not.
I have it on my other piece on my laptop.
Maybe.
Let me check real quick.
No, I don't.
Let me grab it.
Let me grab it again.
No, it was like...
Like, I couldn't plan...
I couldn't have it done earlier.
Because of the...
It was just like...
Everything was such a tight deadline for everything.
Like, it had to be done within a month in time for, like,
prepping...
the concert it's like i wasn't like i had the concept the
moment i realized i had to do the concert i contacted the
people for the 3d outfit and everything so like i couldn't
do it earlier if i like i i didn't have the i couldn't i
didn't have the opportunity to do it earlier so yeah this
was done within a month
because we needed it for it to test out the motion capture
and everything in time so we need it done to test out motion
capture and stuff oh rice thank you the super chat thank you
thank you that means we're gonna see it again right maybe
yeah so huge shout out to them i think it helped because it
was based off the base model already um um and so like all
that it was just like making the outfits because they ground
up it was just re-texturing and uh making the outfits
basically so everything was already like the base the base
model was there so luckily it we were it was possible to to
get it done within a month it's very avro levine inspired
yeah like i said this is like avro levine sat like avro
levine outfit like the tie like i studied avro levine
fashion for this if you guys look at of the cons the if you
guys look at the the concert post-concert birthday
celebration um i gave you i i i uh showed like the
step-by-step concept art that led to this in the end
papa smurf thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
the tie and short commas very well coordinated thank you for
the super chat papa thank you thank you yeah no shorts the
counts the council's wrong i knew what you guys what the
dragon was wanting I know what the people wanted The council
was wrong
They wanted shorts I knew what they actually wanted Didn't I
just win in that VIP postcard 73B reach out eat them Thank
you for the super chat Thank you thank you Oh yeah So if you
guys got the VIP postcard And it has like A and B That meant
I fucked up I and then I was like here's your new side quest
find your everything was I guys I was locked in the bathroom
signing postcards guys I did not want it I was just like you
know let's make it a little fun for you guys so if you were
at the venue and you got a or b that means you have a out
there that have the same number but they're either a or b so
congratulations go find your twin maybe i set you up with a
1v1 guys either either 1v1 them or you guys can like the
buddy system you can be best friends happy little accidents
um next seat thank you the super chat thank you uh we were
debating uh the concert because it was hard to see this the
3d model have a belly button or is it lord that the skin
suit don't have okay you know what's funny
all right i don't even know let's see oh we can't even see
okay well i don't know
but i'll give you guys a little spoiler also we got to
decide you guys want the new outfit next Saturday.
I feel like next Saturday so you guys can have more time to
get ready.
I don't know.
I don't know how you guys are going to need to get ready or
anything.
But like, you know, you guys want to like wait a little
longer for the new outfit reveal for the pajama outfit
reveal?
Or do you want me to rip it off on Sunday?
Saturday?
I see more Saturday.
Okay, next Saturday.
Okay.
I'll give you guys a little funny little spoiler.
here about the I had to like keep asking where's the belly
button
multiple times
let's just say now you're gonna find out if it does exist or
not but I've made that request Also, question where the
belly button went multiple times.
So on Saturday, you're gonna see and find out if it,
you're gonna see and find out if it happens or not.
wait in anticipation there's like trojanger is a belly
button does it exist or not right thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you I will find it
I don't feel better about the fact I asked about butter
butter on the summer and it never got next seat you and me
both maybe it's because it's because birds don't have belly
guys it's only canon it's just real and no next seat don't
worry I've also had to pump that too I think we're just
getting we're just trying to be accurate to the anatomy of
birds it was it's lower accurate
well thank you super chat thank you thank you what's was,
were they the only funny numbers on the, yeah, they were the
only funny numbers, I think.
I had a little, lots of little Easter eggs, um, on, like, I,
I, there was like, Easter eggs scattered in a couple of
postcards.
Um, that's all I could say.
There was just little, I don't remember, I, I drew, there
was like one of each dragoon scattered across all the
postcards, so, and a dad too.
There was one of each dragoon and a dad scattered around the
postcard.
I don't remember the numbers, guys.
I literally was like I didn't do anything yet.
Bro, did that.
And guys, I don't know the numbers.
I can't remember.
I know 250 had something special.
I don't remember what it was.
Oh, 250 was dad.
That's all I can remember.
250 50 had um had was dad's that dad's special number
and i apologize the soap one does not exist they throw away
the the postcard that had soap on it
the numbers what do they mean
what else can i talk about what else from the concert i mean
there's a lot of things that happen i'm trying to remember
what what to what else Am I missing?
Any questions you guys have about the concert or anything
about at an expo?
I bought a lot of clothes, guys.
Oh, yeah.
I broke my suitcase.
My suitcase is broken now.
I need to buy a new suitcase.
Basically, I didn't buy another suitcase.
I didn't buy another suitcase, and I just went They ran out
of post cards?
Wait, Akoda, were you a VIP?
Wait, send us support ticket because they had more
postcards.
I signed 250.
They had more postcards.
But Maki, if you were a VIP and you didn't get a postcard,
send us support ticket or like at me on Twitter because like
everyone should have got postcards.
So if you didn't get it, uh, you might not, they were like
giving postcards.
They were, uh, guys, okay, so if you guys didn't get
postcards, um, oh yeah, they wrote down a lot.
Okay, good.
All right, so they took names and emails.
Okay, there, that's, all right.
That's good.
Yeah, they're gonna be sent your postcard.
Yeah, they locked me in the bathroom.
You guys better get your postcards.
I, yes,
yes, yes, yes, I got locked in the bathroom.
Dude, you guys better get your fucking postcards.
I was signing postcards until the day.
I was signing so many cards.
So, so I hope, guys, if you guys did not end up, you guys
better, you guys will get it.
I will make sure you guys get it.
I, no, I, guys, no, I, I have, I took some postcards home
too.
If I have to, I'll keep signing them.
I was jailed.
I was jailed in a bathroom on my birthday, too.
It's locked in the bathroom on my birthday.
If I have to, I also took some postcards home just in case.
I don't know why, but maybe it was for this exact moment.
The end is never, it was never the end.
What was I talking about before the postcards?
What was I talking about before the postcards, guys?
Oh, I broke my suitcase.
Yeah, so I had too much stuff in my suitcase.
Maki, thank you for the 20 gift and chips.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Next, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Did you get in trouble for not keeping the sloppies panel
PG?
I can't believe you and Mint talked about that.
No, it was good.
It was all right.
We didn't get any warnings or anything at all.
So it was okay.
If you see us invited again at Anime Expo, then that means
we didn't fuck up.
If you see us not getting invited to Anime Expo next year,
then maybe I did get in trouble.
We'll see.
We'll see next year.
if we show up again guys we'll see but yes so um so my staff
told me to buy another suitcase i didn't listen to my staff
i just stuffed it all as as per usual and as you know as
always so i stuffed it all in my one suitcase and it was it
was like i think like um because like 50 it has to be 50
pounds right 50 pounds was the limit so my suitcase was 65
pounds i believe so it was maybe like 15 pounds over the
limit never punished um so um it was sort of a little heavy
you know just a little bit heavy and you know they had to
put a sticker on that where it was like heavy suitcase
so uh no it was 15 it was 15 pounds not 50 15 50 is the is
the maximum you can have before they charge you so instead
of buying another suitcase i just paid the extra price um
maybe i should buy another suitcase because i had to pay
like 50 70 dollars or something like maybe another just
maybe yeah maybe buying another suitcase would have been
cheaper than paying for the over limit um but anyway so when
I came back to Canada um I think because of the extra weight
the wheel got was busted I so it doesn't roll anymore it
made a funny sound so that suitcase has been with me for 10
years, by the way.
I've had that suitcase for... By the way, that suitcase was
made by the Swiss!
I...
I knew it!
I knew there was something wrong with you guys.
I just realized that was a Swiss brand suitcase, too.
I fucking knew it!
I love that explains it.
It was a trip.
It was a fucking Swiss gear.
Oh, I knew it was something wrong with you.
Yes, of course.
That's right.
It was a Swiss gear suitcase.
It always comes back around.
It's sabotage.
Everything is the Swiss.
It's the fault.
It's not.
But it was.
It was a Swiss gear.
Yeah, I knew you were always out to get me.
I fucking knew it.
The saboteur.
Anyway, they got their revenge for the hate watching.
Blame the Swiss.
So, yeah, the suitcase is like 10 plus years old now.
It took 10 years, but they got me.
They knew I came back to hate watch.
So they had like a, they had like those like timers it's
like the what's it called it's like the harley cool uh the
harley quinn shit where what's her name the warden would
have those like bombs implanted the neck and then they
realized i was coming back to hate watch them so they
detonated my they had the switch so they detonated it the
moment i came back they played the lawn con
yeah that's some of mine the wall or shit right there the
dead man switch yeah
i fucking knew it i knew it it's all a conspiracy it blows
the wheels she has turned on the swiss
but anyway yeah my suitcase got fucked So I'm gonna need to
buy a new suitcase before I have to travel again.
I might have to travel, guys.
I won't say for what, but I may or may not have to travel
overseas again in the middle of August.
I'm not fully sure yet, but I need to get a suitcase before
then.
I need to get a suitcase.
Yeah, this is the year of travel, Doki.
I'm so tired of traveling.
though I I'm so I've been traveling so much yet it's it's a
lot I can't say what it is yet though but it's for something
cool I'll let you guys know later when it gets closer I'll
tell you guys what it's definitely not Switzerland it's
that's the one thing
I did not
Hell month It's like hell year Not gonna lie It feels more
like hell year Oh I'll show you guys this one This is funny
Wait let's see Um I'm thinking of what I can show you guys
right now Uh
I'm gonna show you guys That I took photos of I wish I took
a photo of the bathroom When I was locked in Signing card
I wish I could show you guys that I probably did not Oh
yeah, I thought this was funny Oh, this is for the league
players out there You guys will understand But it's from the
Riot Studio Tour
Lad This is for all you league players You get it It was
like randomly, it was like in the middle of the camp.
It was like in the middle of the welcome building.
And they just had this.
They just had that.
Apparently they wrote the Vlad thing in MS Paint, by the
way.
And yeah,
there's a little thing.
All the other non-league players are so confused.
Don't worry, that was me too.
I had to have them explain the joke.
Don't worry guys That was just like you They have to explain
the joke to me
It's apparently an ability
Alright what else can I show you guys
Oh these are cool What okay let me double check Alright so
This one's really cool What I'm gonna show you is I wish it
was on.
It wasn't on when we were there.
Dragos are holding Doki Kahn in Switzerland.
Will you attend?
That's not funny.
That's not funny, guys.
How dare you use my trauma as a joke?
So this, we're confused what this is.
It's like an arcade machine.
But why does it say Valorant is?
bases so um i thought this was really cool um basically um
the riot office people had a um had a game jam and one of
the one of the uh game jammers one of the groups made a
arcade shooter of valorant and they even made like their own
gun and everything it wasn't on when we were there but i
thought that was so cool so you see the gun in the middle so
my trauma is not your costume yeah so so they actually made
uh an arcade shooter at the office uh yeah so that like uh
so they made valorant an arcade shooter i thought it's so
cool yeah it was unfortunate i wasn't on because i would
have tried it out i wanted to try it but it was like off
today
what else can i show you guys this so they had like several
statues on display too i can't wait for the riot tour to
give you guys like a virtual riot tour because he's like uh
jennifer robert's husband is a lot better at describing
stuff than me i was like look there's like the statues and
everything too
so they had like all these cool statues and stuff displayed
and everything yeah I don't want to spoil too much of the
riot stuff only because but then the riot tour will only be
will be set up like a couple of weeks um uh in a couple of
weeks and stuff because we have to send an email to get like
riot like you know officially approved and everything so um
like and the stuff he was just like you know he was a very
good tour guy and i want to spoil too many of the things
because i was like oh oh and then you know i even talked to
the security guards too i was like who was like the most
famous person you met and everything he was like describing
all the people he's met and stuff and i was like oh my god
so i want you guys to get the the pov live reaction of it
all because i think it's very interesting you know but It's
like I'm almost an IRL streamer, but like virtual.
I mean, that's the whole thing regarding like IRL streamers
and why IRL streamers are so popular right now.
It's because they give experiences for people who might not
never get to experience these things before too.
And like, I know that's why like Speed is like, I know like
that's why Speed is like so popular because he's like, you
know, he's right now he's like doing watchalong of like
World Cup and stuff, but he also does like world tours of
different countries everything giving everybody experiences
of uh of like uh visiting different countries and stuff and
i think that's really fun that's a really fun thing the
reason why i don't do convention tours um is because there's
a lot of kids at conventions because i know like um and like
also i know not just that but also um it's like harder to do
stuff like i feel like uh and And I know like some people
have like value privacy and stuff too during like at
conventions.
It's like, because a lot of people that go there is just
like a lot, like go there that are just like for, you know,
for fun and everything.
And this is why I don't stream convention stuff as well.
Because like, you know, I just, you know, I'm just worried
that like, you know, I'll catch someone on camera that
doesn't want to be on camera.
so that's why i i i don't stream any of the convey like but
like for this tour stuff i'm fine with tours and stuff
because it's like uh i'm fine with tours because it's like
more so like it's a specific guided tour and a lot of people
are there that work at riot as well so and they'll know that
it's being we have we'll get permission from the studio as
well and from there like since we have permission from the
studio they're aware the workers will be aware that we're
doing this So it's more private in a way.
It's also why I don't like.
I it's also why like for meeting greets and stuff.
I like like one to one meeting greet where it feels more
personal.
Because I want you guys to have a more personal chat with
me.
Because I know there's like some meeting greets that are
like broadcasted.
or like that are like live or not just live but like on a
big screen but like i like having more personal meet and
greets because i want you guys to have a special moment with
me because especially if it's like a paid thing too so like
i want you guys to have a special moment with me and it's
more i felt like it's more personal because if you don't
want to talk to me personally uh you know if you want to say
something you don't want like other people to hear you know
you don't want other people to hear what you say um so i
want to give you guys a chance to say whatever you want say
without having to worry about like oh um being like
embarrassed or anything
because it's a it's hard i know it's really hard to get meet
and greets and stuff too because it's like all lottery
system as well that's why i like having like smaller like
more personal meet and greets so i'm able to have like a
one-on-one with you guys
i know one more convention later um this month This is for
Tekko.
I believe TekkoCon.
So that's my...
I would meet and greet for that.
I'll see you guys at Tekko!
That's why I always do like more than two minutes.
I love the ones shared on stream, but those opportunities
must be fun.
I think like...
I think it's like to each their own type deal.
Because I also want to make sure you guys are okay with
being on stream too
because i want you guys to like be caught off guard when
you're on stream so you know consent is important so we have
to be okay if you're you want to be on stream because on
stream you're like you know you're in my vods you know and
if i ever do like a stream meet and greet or a streamed
panel um I want to be sure that you're okay with being on
the channel or you're being you're okay um being on camera
you know because digital footprint and everything you know
like well your boss sees this it's like who is this nerd I'm
joking I'm joking your boss sees it and you're like wait a
minute they said they were sick today yeah yeah yeah i was
like wait a minute they said they wanted three days off
because they're sick today why are they on toky bruce
channel
yeah i don't yeah he's supposed to be at work right now i
don't want that to happen to you guys
hi boss it's like oh no way it is like the day you found
your boss is also a dokeybird fan and then it was the day
you also got fired
it's the day you got fired
you and fire fell a dragon right boss papa's for yeah but he
got jealous because he was like wait a minute you got the
dokeybird lottery ticket and i did it that's gonna make it
mad
You're just making him even more mad.
It was like, I didn't get a lottery ticket, but he did.
Next, see, they get a super chat.
Thank you.
And they're watching your stream.
The lottery is Jen, right?
You got the meet and get out.
Dude, you should have told me what the fuck, though.
That way to go to get it.
You got the meet and greet.
And you didn't even give it to me.
your paychecks then solid snake to use super chat thank you
thank you dude you should have told me what the fuck
not even a plus one all right let me see what else i can
what else i took pictures of let me check my photos i'm
trying not to show too much from the uh from the ride stuff
because I want to show you guys the actual, the virtual toy.
Boss, please don't fire me.
I'll give you the top 10 number Doki Rewind postcard.
B &G, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I'm just looking through my photos right now.
That one of my employees of YouTube are found.
We're both at the end.
Oh, that's so cool.
Nightmare scenario.
Ciao, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but you guys can, like, share now.
You guys can, like, share your experience.
I think that's pretty neat.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I posted, like, a picture of the...
So, my staff post-concert, my staff took me to eat tacos,
because they were, like, you gotta eat, like, real Mexican
food.
they took me to the place I think some people in LA might
know this place but basically they're sort of there they're
not illegally like um because I asked I asked that I don't
remember if I told the story but I asked my staff I was just
like oh like uh by the way yes the picture I took was like
without the salsa or like the the cilantro and stuff because
um it was like all you can put toppings and I took the
picture before I put the toppings on because I wanted you
guys to see Because I took a picture of it with the
toppings, but you guys can't even see the meat at all.
So I showed the meat one, because I got like one of
everything.
But basically, the restaurant is technically not like
registered.
Because I asked them.
I asked my staff, I was like, oh, this place is really good.
What is it called?
And then one of the staff was, I don't remember what the
place is called.
They were like, oh, it's, and then the other staff, like,
no, no, no, they're called this now, and then the other
staff, like, are you sure?
I remember they changed your names to this, and I was like,
why do they have so many different names?
And then my staff was like, oh, they're not supposed to be
here.
So they have to keep changing their names, so they don't get
caught.
Yeah.
Yeah, so, yeah.
Yeah, but I thought that was funny.
I was like, why do they have deep...
Why doesn't, like, the restaurant have, like, you know...
Why does the restaurant have a different name every time?
But you know, it's apparently...
Oh, shit, sorry.
I thought it was...
Does anyone know what it's called now?
Because they don't know what it's called anymore.
I don't know.
I don't remember what...
It's apparently really famous in LA.
And it's between, uh, it's between like, uh, what's it
called?
It's between Little Tokyo and somewhere else.
You're like, why?
Why do you want to know, Doki?
You a cop or something?
Guys, guys, calm down.
Calm.
I was just, I'm just curious.
Yeah, Doki, why do you want to know what it's called?
You're trying to rat the...
Guys, calm down, everyone.
I'm just curious.
I'm just curious what they're called now.
Yes, it's Taco.
Taco the 26th.
So...
That shit is so...
Apparently, they started off...
Whatever you say, God.
She's clearly a fan.
So, if you're all, any of you ever go to LA, apparently
that's the authentic taco place.
It's called Tacos the 26.
And, uh, Doki just urgently.
Quick, change the name.
So, apparently, it started off as, like, them selling out of
a truck.
Um, I was like, the back of the truck.
And then it got more and more popular to a point where they
finally have, like, a stall.
for people to so it because they don't have tables or
anything and like everyone that comes over there to order
tacos um they until they change the name everyone who goes
over there um to order tacos um they would just eat at the
hood of their car or at the back of the cars car and then
like and they're like yeah that's authentic mexican food
that's when you know that's when you know It's really good,
though.
Yeah.
They've been here for three to four years now.
That's cool.
But it's really, really good.
I don't remember what their old name was.
Oh, previously out of 26 tacos.
I don't know how many times they name changed.
But I had a good time.
I had a good time eating tacos there.
I also had a horchata.
If it's got I'm gonna blame you.
Yeah, they had horchadas, too.
Because I was confused.
I was just like...
I was like...
I was like, why do they keep changing names?
And then my staff was like, they're not supposed to be here.
I was like, why?
And it's like, they...
She was just like, they're...
It's really good.
She's like, this place is really good, Doki.
Wait, I think it was nice.
It was my first time.
Why are you asking so many questions, huh, Doki?
Are you copying something?
I was curious.
guys.
I was just wanting to know.
The more illegal dinner is the tastier.
Stop asking questions and eat your tacos.
Oh, Orchada.
It's good.
It was my first time having Orchada.
Why are you curious, huh?
Probably here last year.
time no i know a lot of people were apparently uh a lot of
people went there post anime expo i don't i don't unless oh
yeah the reason why i'm expo was so crowded too for artist
houses was because there's still construction going on there
so a lot of places were just super it was just super cramped
in general because of it which sucks like oh yeah i spent uh
i'll show you guys my I always say this, I'll show you guys
my haul and I never do.
Guys, I swear to God, I will show you guys my Anime Expo
haul.
You won't.
You never unpack.
That's true.
There were all the times I was like, guys, don't worry.
I'll show you guys what I bought in Japan.
I'll show you guys what I bought in Korea.
I'll show you guys what I bought last Japan trip two years
ago.
Guys, do not worry.
I'll show you guys.
what I got in Anime Expo.
Eventually.
Every time I travel, I unpack.
I don't believe you.
Toki.
You never unpack.
Guys, I swear to God.
I'll show you guys what I got in Anime Expo.
Guys, I swear.
this time for real you'll see what i got at anime expo yes
but when though toky when will you show one toky yes toky
don't worry toky will show it at this point doing unboxing
unpacking a past travel streams thoughts on thank you in the
super chat thank you thank you guys guys i'll show you guys
time guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
it's been 84 years
what else what else i want to tell you guys about i'm trying
to think right now what else did i do like i said it was all
work i felt like i just worked in la like the for the entire
time i'm
like looking through my notes
oh yeah but i'm really happy about like this i i cannot wait
to see all the dragons wearing the sweat band because we
match now too yeah dad's back that's just been sleeping
oh yeah tomorrow guys um if you guys didn't know marvel
rivals has essentially become marvel rivals too
who don't know why am i streaming particularly uh to for the
newest season of marvel rival season nine for those who
haven't been keeping track don't worry same here um i didn't
realize how different the because i you know i i was
traveling in la so for those who didn't know basically it's
literally marvel rivals too it felt like all the other
seasons of marvel rivals was just beta we were in beta for
we were basically in like open beta in marvel rivals and now
marvel rivals 1.0 has finally released um so they changed
everything um every character has new new abilities new team
ups um and then so you can use your team ups without the
actual characters on your team so it's entirely different
game now and then if you have the character when your team
up on your team it just upgrades your entire kit essentially
so like example cloak has a freeze now she can freeze
herself to be invulnerable and then another example would be
loki can after he kills someone he can clone himself as that
character and use themselves as that character so stuff like
that so every character in marvel rivals has a new update
and um yeah and like it's different it's all different
they're all broken so uh also black panther can one shot you
now yeah so she can may ice cube yeah sorry that is a dagger
sorry dagger was the one that can freeze I don't even know I
don't I think you do it for both cloak and dagger um they
buff the fuck out of everybody to the point where everything
everything is broken no one can be a bad character if
everybody is a broken character if everything is buffed then
no there's no such thing as a bad character so oh yeah they
reworked widow by the way um they reworked word to which
she's not a sniper character i think that's the craziest
part she's not a sniper anymore if everything is broken no
one is exactly so the only way widow can snipe is if she
alts and then she would have five bullets or some shit i
don't fucking know i didn't look into it too much but like
black widow is now not even a anymore yeah she's not they've
reworked it yeah she's no her only time the only time she
can snipe is in her alt form and so they made her easier to
play yeah she has a dmr now what else what else was crazy i
was so many great yeah and she she can't even yeah she still
can't one shot by the way, she can't one-shot in her alt.
Like, what's the point?
Her sniper has an alt, but, like, she can't even one-shot.
I still... I was like, at least, like, if it's an alt, at
least let it one-shot, but I thought it was funny.
What was she?
Yeah, that's so funny.
Oh, yeah.
Also, tanks can self-heal i thought it was so we're gonna
look through all of that tomorrow what's the point so so
tanks can now self-heal and it's so funny because there's a
self there's a stats for tanks right to heal like then
people were like if i out heal my supports as a tank i will
block i
yeah yeah
that can happen
yeah there's so tanks can now selfie up there it's crazy
it's so fucked oh yeah invisible woman has a team up where
she makes everybody invisible I was like holy shit where am
I my marbles too let's fucking party guys it's like you're
relearning the whole game you're literally we're basically
relearning everything everything is different nothing is the
same anymore I don't even know how I'll play this game
anymore
yeah she can make her entire team invisible in one of her
team ups so that's tomorrow what if both teams go invisible
at the same time and everyone's like We're hiring Yeah,
it's season zero all over again
Oh yeah, they're bringing back the Hella team-ups by every
team-up Every team-up you know Like since season zero
They're back You just have to pick it You can pick your
team-ups basically So you can have the So Hella team-ups
like The Hella, Thor, Loki team-up Where she kills someone
and you can bring back Loki And Thor that's back Every
single team up, they're back.
It's just YOLO now.
We're just letting it ride.
Not an offense.
Yeah, and also, Hela can move in her bird form.
Oh, yeah.
Adam, Mantis, Starlight, that's back.
It's back, baby.
Everything is back.
Oh, and Jeff has a Cancer Ray.
Like, the what?
sell cancer I'm sorry I'm spoiling it for all of you guys
right now so um for those who want context Jeff now has a
special team up with the Hulk where he can spit out the
green goop on the people so he has a cancer gun Jeff you
gave me cancer wait was that fake sorry that might be fake
spreading misinformation.
That was the one that was fake.
I thought that one was real.
There were so many like, guys, the cra- There were so many
changes.
That's my guilt.
Guys, that one might've been the only one that's fake.
It's not?
Never mind.
JK, it's real.
Guys, I can't tell there's so many new things.
JK, I baited your bait.
I baited the bait.
That was real.
He has cancer, Ray.
JK.
It's actually real.
No, it's which one is it?
We'll find out tomorrow, guys.
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow we'll find out.
If the cancer gun is real or not
I know the other stuff I said was real though There are so
guys there's so many team ups You guys I cannot keep track
It's literally a whole new game guys It's a whole new
fucking game That's why we're streaming Marvel Rivals
tomorrow It's an entirely new It's a new environment
It's gonna be wild Anyway that's everything I want to talk
about Any questions open the room for questions.
It's now a TED Talk.
Oh,
no.
My algorithm is just lads.
I fucked up, guys.
I clicked on too many lads.
I clicked on too many lads to share you guys the lads
tweets.
And now my algorithm is the lads.
Is it true that Storm can heal now?
Oh yeah, Storm can heal now too.
She has an ability where she summons a rainstorm and you get
healed by Storm.
Will this be included in tomorrow's test?
Oh yeah, I saw someone ask about the set list.
I mean, I know someone took a picture.
I should have asked for this.
I should have asked for it.
I didn't realize they printed a sheet out of this.
Oh yeah, by the way, I have so many new clothes.
Now I'm so happy.
I bought so many new clothes.
you for um for the tweet you posted about the set list can
everyone just do everything yes oh yeah and she's hit scan
now it's just it like just yolo fuck it if everybody's
broken no one is oh i think the funniest part the funniest
part about the thing is that their land is in two weeks I
think that's the funniest part the Marvel rivals final land
like the land is in two weeks so all the pro players have to
let got to figure out what the fuck to do in two weeks bro
what and then people were like really mad because the teams
that got eliminated from the land would have prospered in
this meta no it's on this patch it's on this patch so
apparently there were some pro teams that got eliminated
that got knocked out but like their team was like Their
comps would have benefited from this patch.
It's not even the same game now.
Exactly.
I think that's crazy.
Oh yeah, here we go.
Here's the set list.
Shout out to Nexy.
So it was Skater Boy.
Because every time we touch, I get this feeling.
And it's technologic.
Um, bye And then Thousand Miles I love this song And then I
told you guys, I told you guys I'm gonna speak a little
Español in YSET I told you I was gonna speak a little
Spanish Um, and then This was like a duet with Chibi, bop to
the top and she we did pap pineapple apple pen uh running in
the 90s and I did caramel dancing uh with chibi and then I
did Pokemon and then I made you guys sing happy birthday to
me and then um I did field gold with shachi or a thousand
miles with Amaline every time we touch with Nimi thanks for
the memories with shachi uh call me Mami um call me Mami
baby.
I wanted to do Justin Bieber baby, but then we didn't get
perms for it.
So maybe in the future guys, I will say, um, I love live
band.
I think the live band enhances the experience of a concert,
especially the concerts I want to do.
I think in the future, I'm going to try my best to have my
future concerts incorporate a live band because I feel like
that enhances the experience like uh on and i was talking to
my staff about it but um whenever i do another concert um
it'll have a live band for sure i'll do more of these types
of concerts more uh but yeah that's a guarantee i'll make
sure uh i will not do another concert unless i have a live
band how did i get pokemon perms i don't know i just looked
it up on jazz rack
That's it.
I just went on Jazz Rack and was like, Pokemon.
And I was like, yeah.
Pokemans.
Yeah.
WannaBee 99 Red Balloons.
So I'll tell you what I want.
Oh yeah, but if you guys didn't watch Limelestream, she was
the one that hard pushed for WannaBee.
We've had WannaBee as a thing that we wanted to do for a
while.
now um and then space jam we couldn't do it so i was like
all right lamo we're doing wannabe you did it um best of
both worlds so yeah best of both worlds was duet with me and
me uh 99 red balloons was a duet with dubi uh and i was
suggested by dubi and then encore song with everyone but
nimi and amaline because like they were last minute
additions so we couldn't So we I wish if we had time We
would have been able to fit them But like I said they were
like last minute additions to the concert So we had So it's
just like it was everybody else But Nimi and Amali I had a
list of songs I got perms for it And then she picked from my
list She was like oh I want to do this or this And I was
like oh we should do it every time we touch Because I think
that would be the best choice for both of That would fit the
both of us the best um also shout out for neemie for taking
the high harmonies because originally we're gonna swap
harmonies and stuff but i legit could not hit the high notes
i was like i was like i had to like swap heart like i had to
swap harmonies with her and give her all the high harmonies
because i could not sing those notes i mean i could if i i
think like i could if i try really really hard but like i
did not have the time to try really really hard
The balloons was my idea.
It was my idea from the very beginning.
I asked if I could... I asked if I could...
Originally, but like...
It was originally supposed to drop at the...
at the drop of 99 red balloons go by and then the balloons
dropped.
But then it got dropped too early.
It got dropped before the song started.
By that point I was just like, fuck it!
It's all live!
We're doing it!
We're doing it live!
Yeah, look mom, my hand's on stream Quill, thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you Oh, credit Quill for letting
me take photos I said, listen, hold me while I took a photo
next to you Super chat, thank you, thank you I was like,
well, fuck it What happens, happens We can't do anything to
stop it
If it happens, if it happens it happens
first something I want to talk about what I was talking
about before the set list
I had something in my mind but I forgot what it was
trying to remember I had something in my head but I forgot
what it was guys guys help me remember
what I was talking about before I talked about the set list
guys
I forgot too guys Oh no We're both forgetting
No it was after rivals It was after rivals It was before the
set list What was it I can't remember
My cat are we old Oh my god people People have Holland
Holland like Oshi cards now I saw this pop up in my
algorithm Honestly true
That's her Oshi What
Save us Holland I think Holland's getting all the fan art
too He just has such an interesting physique and face and
hair and everything I don't know the Holland effect he is
married his wife is hot that's
his wife was also uh uh his wife is was also a football
player yeah it's his wife is a childhood sweetheart too
which I thought I was cute bro's winning bro bro is winning
for those who don't know yeah so like they met each other
during like football camp when she also used to play in the
same on the women's team in the same club as him back in
like football camp and um and then like uh they were like
good friends and stuff and a couple years later uh he got
signed and she messaged like she DMed him and was like oh
congratulations and then they got together after that I
thought it was really cute.
They were used to be friends as teenagers when they were
teenagers.
That's right.
I know the Holland.
I know the Holland dating history.
Because I was like...
Because I looked on Wikipedia and I saw he was married.
And I was like, who is Holland's wife?
Also, they have a son together.
I read the lore.
um so uh and then so also they have a son and then i was
like who is holland's wife and i read their lore i was
curious all right i was not actively searching up if he's
married or not it was just in his wikipedia and i got
curious i i got curious I was just like, who's his wife, you
know?
Because also, like, you know, it must be super intense to,
like, date one of the most famous people in the world right
now.
Or not date, be married.
Be married to one of the most famous, like, football player
in the world.
Is he not married?
Well, he has a kid.
Beyonce I thought he was married Because I thought Because I
know he has a kid Yeah they're just Yeah they just got
married right They just got married
People can have kids while getting married But what about
the tax benefits?
Also I fixed my tax problems today Toki What do you Don't
worry about it
it's fixed now I'm gonna say what don't worry about it it's
fixed now let me do not elaborate IRS she's right here
unrelated to how getting married fixes gives you tax
benefits it's unrelated i just thought about taxes and how
much i love paying my taxes and how i how i'm contributing
to canadian government
yeah sure wait a minute
I love taxes.
In fact, I wish they taxed me more.
That's how much I love taxes.
Oh yeah, you guys know about the Canadian census?
I almost fucked up.
I didn't fuck up.
But like,
for those who don't know, the Canadian census is like
mandatory for every Canadian to do the fucking census.
census um what is it's a survey that everyone in Canada has
to take so they I guess no we like I don't know they know
we're alive I guess yeah so um so it's like it's like
basically everyone in Canada has to take it no matter what
and if you don't take it they find you and they'll know by
the way because I forgot about it and then so they visited
my apartment two times because I forgot about it twice by
the way when they visited me it was during hell year hell
month by the way when I was like prepping for this concert
so um so they like have a record of whether or not you did
this it's a very important super serious and so um so
obviously I had a lot of stuff going on forgot about doing
the census and then they were like you we're gonna text you
now like so i got textified and be like did you do the
census toky remember to do the census like they started
texting me and visiting my apartment to do the census anyway
i didn't have to pay the fine though guys it's okay i didn't
pay the fine i did the census
I just didn't have I just keep forgetting to do it because I
was I was so busy But I didn't get fined though guys it's
okay I didn't get fined so I did the census It's just the
Canadian thing you Americans don't have it but we do
Yeah, they will keep coming by your door every every other
day every two to three days they'll visit you I got visited
twice And also texted, like, three times.
Yeah, but then ours is, like, every year.
Which is a little too many years.
Oh, you guys have it once every 10 years?
We have it, like, every year, which I think is a little bit
too many.
It's just a little bit.
I feel like we could tone that down a little.
I feel like we don't...
We don't need it that many times.
It's every other year.
I lost track.
Like, it's not...
How many?
I feel like it happens too often.
It feels like every year for me.
Is it every five years?
Did I just...
I feel...
Is it every five years?
Okay, it just felt like too many times.
Yeah, that's still too many.
It's every five years.
taking it too many times.
Time sure flies.
You're keeping a closer eye on me.
It felt too many times.
Cause I was just like, man, I want, oh man.
I'm hallucinating you early senses.
I am.
I was like, can't wait to do another senses.
Are they still playing the aisle?
The aisle is hardcore.
How long have they been grinding out the aisle?
Wait, sure if we're just starting streaming?
This late?
Oh, it's 10.30.
Oh, no, he swapped.
I was just wondering.
I was just like...
The y'all is fun with friends though.
It's pretty.
Pretty fun.
They love dinos.
I'm trying to...
I'm still trying to remember the thing I want to talk about.
But I forgot what it was.
I'm trying to remember.
Fuck!
I wanted to talk about something specific.
Anyway guys, any other questions you guys want to ask about
the concert or Anime Expo or LA?
Maybe I'll remember it while we talk.
anything else you want to ask me
I didn't visit a lot of places like I said I basically every
where I told you guys that's where I was I didn't do much
like I said I went out to Mexico I my concert next day they
get a super chat they get thank you yeah like um the Mexican
food place Korean barbecue um um also thank you for the
radio we had a good stream t thank you thank you uh i think
that's it there was no standee uh they weren't able to make
it in time of thing i think uh but they didn't tell me so i
thought there was a standee and i was like where did the
standee go when is spawn fixing the vaude the vaude's fixed
it's fixed now My cards are back.
Yeah, I had it.
My my my staff helped me fix.
Oh, yeah, I saw.
Oh, yeah, I saw Matara and Amalee.
I did.
I hanged out with Matara and Amalee for a little bit.
Um, Amalee was there for the ride tour with me.
Um, and I gave Matara.
Uh, I didn't know anything about wine, but I gave everyone I
first, um, everyone I meet for the first time.
I always give them a gift because that's how my parents
raised me.
Um, I don't know.
It's an Asian thing.
I don't know if you guys know this, but.
It's an Asian thing where like when you meet someone for the
first time you give them a gift Um, um, and so like every
time I it's something I would always my I would always do
growing up Whenever I meet like coaches or like friends or
whatever my parents will always pack a little gift For them
for me to give to them.
Um, so uh, and then you know when I became adult I do I
still Continue to do that so I always give a gift to people
I've come to meet for the first time So you know I I gave
Amelie in her.
I'll meet something something like when I first met her in
Korea and for Matara you know and also some Canadian like
Canadian things like maybe like maple syrup and stuff but
Matara's Canadian to so I was just like, well I obviously I
can't give her like Canadian things because she's Canadian
so I get I was at the airport and I was just I bought like
the most expensive while it wasn't the most expensive wine
obviously but like it like it seemed like a pricey wine and
I know she likes red wine I know she likes wine so um so I I
don't know anything about wine I don't know anything about
wine and I was like oh this seems like an expensive wine so
I just gave I gave her wine and also um and also some cause
uh cosmetic I can't say what it is uh but all right i'll say
what it is actually but uh i gave all the other girls this
too so i gave like um so there's the same gift i gave rin uh
amelie and iron mouse uh but it was basically a little
chanel hand lotion that shaped like a it's a chanel hand
lotion and it's something that it's just something my mom
would always pack uh for me to give to people and i saw it
at the airport too so then i was just like oh uh you know
it's like a little hand lotion so it's like fancy and it's
uh it's nice they people always tell me that like everyone
that uh received it always said it was if was really nice so
then i gifted that to matara too so it's just a little thing
that was uh that's just been like a staple in like what i
give people so it's like something something that's related
it's i don't i always have the chanel hand lotion because
it's like something like you know all the ladies like and
then and then if it's someone that's not from Canada I gift
like you know some Canadian stuff um like you know like
maybe maple syrup uh Canadian chocolate maple syrup uh
Canadian chocolates or smoked salmon stuff like that um just
like a Canadian experience but if it's someone I know from
Canada then I give
like for Matara I knew she likes wine so then I got her wine
yeah so yeah no it was great seeing Matara I met this is the
first time I've ever met Matara in real IRL too we just
never had a chance to cross paths in person before
and so this is the first time I ever got a meter and and she
she's I don't want to explain.
She's really nice and she's very tall.
Jeez.
I'm, I'm boob height to her.
That like, and I had like, in my, I was wearing shoes that
had like a bit of platform.
And then, and then so, yeah, no, I, I, I, I literally
directly at her boobs.
Like, and then if I, so like, I was like, my head, so I had
a little, bit of a platform shoes just a little bit um and
so my head at least was like a bit above the boobs but if i
take it off it would be like full boobs it would be full
boobs yeah perfect i hate she's very tall it's very nice
meeting here like seeing her for the first time
So you mean the perfect Some would say that I know you
jealous That should have been me Jealous
She's very tall Yeah No she's very tall
She was really busy though It was very hard to meet up with
her Because like I said She was like super If you guys
didn't know Like during Anime Expo She had like a bunch of
sponsors and a bunch of things to do at anime expo almost
every day Because she was sponsored by Nike too to do stuff
with them I gotta meet her mom.
I also gotta meet Amelie's mom Wait, actually no I didn't
get to meet her mom.
I met Amelie's mom.
I didn't meet her mom.
I met her security guard I met I met Matara's security
guard.
I didn't meet her mom
But I met Amelie's mom.
Amelie's mom's cool as hell, bro.
She's cool.
You know.
You know she.
You know she was a cool girl back in her day.
Matara did have security guard with her.
All right.
What other questions do you guys have?
Guys.
Questions.
Concerns.
It's a Q&A.
now, but for free.
Sounds sleepy.
I've just been a lot of work stuff going on, you know?
Yeah, of course I got the hug, Matar.
How was it when I found out I was Boopite?
Guys, that was what I found out.
How long is streaming tickets and merchandise for the
concert?
I'll see if we can extend the streaming tickets.
I don't know if we can, because it's via spawn so i feel
like there's a contract with that but we'll see how it goes
i'll ask about the merchandise too like i said merchant
streaming tickets are out of my jurisdiction um so i have to
ask about it
so happy for you
but right now it's officially one week of the vaad left
oh yes there will be more merch dropping during merch will
be dropping during the reveal because it was supposed to be
birthday merch so that was originally supposed to be
birthday merch so birthday slash new outfit reveal merch
will be dropping out on next Saturday and I told you guys
about the limited edition 69 hand signed hand decorated
checkies good luck good luck everybody There's gonna be only
69 because I get to decide the inventory, so I decided 69.
Nice.
It'll be next Saturday.
Next, see, will the updated VOD with the notes actually be
done before the VOD.
It better, it should be.
It better be.
Next, see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I worked so hard on these notes.
But, no, like, ah, man.
But yeah, concert was was an experience to do with a lot
like first time live band Like I said, I definitely next
concert.
I think all my future concerts I would want I would want a
live band I don't think I want to do a concert with a live
band now after that I think it just enhances the overall
experience so much especially like it makes a on-venue
concert a more special in a way.
Yeah
I would limit myself with one a year though Because like I
said It's weird that Stoli started becoming an idol I
thought I was just a gamer You know I just play video games
But I do do gaming stuff too Like but like I never thought
I'd see myself Stoli going into like the The singing route I
don't do a tour I think that would be fun I think that would
be too much work
I would want to do my next concert outside of the US I want
to do in Canada because then the currency will be better for
people outside of Canada and then you guys can help the
Canadian economy too I think next concert I want it in
Canada so you guys can help the Canadian economy
Yeah, he's so, yeah, so patriotic.
Yeah.
Isn't that bad?
You feel like, if you are American with your American
dollars, you will feel like a king in Canada.
Except for Vancouver.
That's just normal.
We get to help.
What's the word help pump the help help the economy the
tourism economy there's a word for it This message was
approved by the government of Canada.
I'm doing my part
There's a special word for it To help uh stimulate uh
stimulating the local economy.
Is that the word for it?
Yeah.
We'll just not do it in Vancouver.
Because that just feels like you're in America anyway.
That just, it doesn't, that just feels like you're in
America anyway, anywhere but there.
Yeah.
I think my next concert, I was talking to my staff about it.
I want it in Canada next.
As I feel like there's so many concerts in America.
So I want to do somewhere different as in like in Canada So
also I heard like I'm sorry to everybody in America I heard
UPS raise their prices for like shipping and stuff So like
you know You know we all win You get things Americans get
stuff cheaper And then you help the Canadian economy Yeah
Maybe I'll get knighted in Canada my for my contribution to
the canadian economy she's a government plan it's a win-win
well for me i can't you can't guys unlike the prime unlike
the presidency you can't get you can't get like elected to
be prime minister unfortunately I have to be actually part
of a party.
Unfortunately, the party elects the prime minister.
It's a parliamentary system, unfortunately.
Well, not with that attitude.
You know what would be?
The Green Party would be the easiest to get into politics
for those who are who are curious and then like they have
what two seats or something sorry a little bit of politics
talk Canadian Canadian political politics is very confusing
you would think American politics are is confusing with how
the system is like but Canadians make it more uh make it
more confusing than it should be yeah yeah
that's that's all i'll say about politics next you think it
was super chat thank you thank you it's a lot more confusing
you think american politics are confusing but like then you
learn about canadian politics it's like wait it's it's it's
weird glad you had a great time in la and i love to go in
person you got constant The next time you see Matara, you
got a monster ace here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can tell Matara that.
Yeah, but that's all.
But anyway, guys, any more final thoughts?
Oh, my God.
I've been yapping for four hours.
I can't help but miss you guys.
It's been so long.
We haven't hanged down in a while.
I was been so busy, too.
I miss telling you guys all my adventures in LA and the
concert.
It's been really fun.
I feel like I talked about during the concert, during my
post-concert stream.
And like, it didn't feel like four hours.
I did not feel like a yap for four hours, too.
Yeah, time went by so fast.
Yeah, I missed hanging out with you guys.
I always miss hanging out with you guys.
I love streaming for you guys.
If I didn't, I'd be gone.
If I didn't, the stream would not exist.
chat thinking thank you uh sorry that's probably our fault
probably because we're we have a little bit of every country
in canada
yeah i would have never came back but i'm here i came back
that means i that means i love doing this i mean it's true i
get the milk i didn't get the milk so that means i have no
excuse to go away again
Always never get the milk when you come back.
So you always have an excuse to get the milk, guys.
A little bit of a pro tip for all you dads out there.
Always forget to get the milk back.
No, not the milk.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You said you were good at fading.
Well, you said you were a master at it.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think I'm good at baiting and being a master at it.
Um, gotta vote.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
That's everything.
Let me see.
Let me think.
I get everything I want to talk about today.
Hmm.
Thank you.
I'm thinking right now that I got everything I want to talk
about I have so many things to talk about I don't know I
must have I slept for four hours I remember the thing I
don't know if I remember that thing I don't know huh hmm um
Petty Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
God, I love Doki's humble aspiration to be knighted in
Canada when she's already a duchess.
Yeah, I could always want more.
Pat, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Never stop reaching for things.
Aphelion, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm thinking right now.
Always reach higher, guys.
Never stop at, never hurts to ask.
I'd be ambitious.
I hate when I like, I wish I remember what I wanted to say
earlier before the set list.
It was something, it was not related to set list.
I know that for sure.
I'm like, what was it?
Next, they give the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you getting a chance to rest or is it back into the
grind?
I think it's back into the grind.
The grind never stops.
they give the super chat.
Thank you.
There's so many things I have to do.
I have to like, restart uh not restart but i have to go back
because i put everything on pause because of the concert so
including rest of tuber so rest of tuber was supposed to be
uh next month or it was supposed to schedule for next month
but we had to push that back just literally because of the
concert i had to put that full stop like i literally
couldn't work on rest of tuber anymore because i had to work
on the concert um so um because of that rest tuber got
pushed back further because of it.
Because like everything, because I was about starting the
plannings of it, but because of that, I had to like move it
to another date.
And I want to be sure I have everything down before I even
think about like announcing it.
Yeah.
So like everything got pushed back because of it.
Like I had plans for a bigger birthday celebration, but with
the con, that's why I also want, like I don't want to do
concert um because I want to do something different on my
birthday I like doing different things I like new things
different things and stuff and so I like for the concert I
was like I don't want to do it in LA anymore I want to do it
somewhere else because I always want to do drive for
something new and some like I always want to do new things I
want to experiment new things I don't want to like go like
same old same old stuff um like doing a live band that's
something new I haven't done yet so now I want to do
something different where I do it somewhere else like new a
new country I still want to do a live band because I think
live band is the way to go when it comes to concerts only
because I feel like the experience for it was just um it's
just um I just think it adds so much to a concert experience
uh so I want to do like something new on my birthday um I
always want to do new things I want to experiment with new
stuff because I think like that's what I like about my
career what i like about my career is i like to experiment i
like to try new things and stuff like this year is like this
year is international do i want to say international this
year is traveling doki traveling slash performing uh doki
this year i don't know what last year was what was last year
doki i don't remember what last year doki was but i know for
this year it's like
singing doki.
I don't even remember what I did last.
Oh, I did stuff last year.
Tournament doki.
Yeah, last year was, last year was tournament doki.
See what are there, I'm going to look through some stuff
just to be sure I didn't forget anything.
Um, but, oh yeah, original songs had to also be put on hold
because of everything, because I didn't have the voice, like
I had to record songs for concerts and other stuff too.
So because of that, I put, because original songs are
personal projects, but I have like sponsors and other like
sponsors and concerts and all that stuff.
And so all my original songs stuff had to be put on hold
because of it because I just didn't have the voice to sing.
I just had so many other, like I just, I needed to, I just
didn't have the, uh i just need to rest my throat in between
singing too so uh original stuff had to be put on hold
because of it next thing is super chat thank you thank you i
noticed how much more you've been traveling i know we talked
about in-person concerns before proud of you for stepping
out of your comfort zone a bit more thank you thank you
thank you i still have my um what's it called i still have
my limits um i still have my what's it berry it was berries
no uh when you have like rules when it comes to like meeting
people.
Oh, what's the word called?
Boundaries?
Yeah, I saw boundaries when it comes to meeting people or
like...
And so, yeah, so in Anime Expo and stuff, I was mostly
alone.
Yeah, most of the time, I was alone when it came to Anime
Expo.
Because I didn't want people to...
Because I was trying to be incognito, obviously.
And so, I was basically like walking around alone most of
the time because i knew like uh especially like matara and
amali they're all like uh you know uh people know what they
look like and stuff so um and also like my staff and stuff
so mostly i was just walking around alone um but i like when
i hanged up with them um we chose like we met up like not
near anime expo that bit yeah you know you know i'm just
like as long as we're not near anywhere that is like the hot
zone yeah yeah so
away from the hot zone exactly i didn't even buy my own
merch i gave up during artist alley yeah but i was gonna do
midnight match alone I was gonna go with anybody I just
wanted to see what it was like I didn't get chance to do
midnight Maja I didn't get to see the feet juice that's
curious I was like what the fuck you know because everyone
always made jokes about feet juice and it's like oh see that
like see the the what it was like
yeah there's so many people at midnight Maja like
it wasn't they lied no
Wait, I wasn't there at midnight, Maja.
Wait, I still had, like, boundaries and stuff.
Like, for the...
Because, like, you know, I still want to be safe and
everything.
Alright, guys.
I kept saying I'm calling here, but I kept talking.
Alright, this time for real.
I'm calling here, guys.
Very great yapping with all you guys.
I hope I didn't miss anything.
thing um thank you everybody for the birthday wishes um i
wish i could maybe uh during the outfit reveal i'll show
more because i know a lot of you guys did some amazing stuff
during the but today's stream i just wanted to chill more
and just like hang out and talk about la and then um maybe
during the outfit reveal we'll talk more about the birthday
stuff and all the stuff you guys uh sent like drew all the
gift art all the fan art all the birthday art all the
birthday project that you guys do i'll do that on sat next
saturday during the outfit reveal we'll do the double whammy
on that but today i just wanted to hang out and chill i
didn't want to do like anything um i didn't want to i didn't
have any really big plans for today i just wanted to like
get back into streaming again and just rev up warm up you
know today was just a warm up for me uh before i get back
into the grind again jacotta think it was super chat thank
you thank you um But thank y'all for the birthday wishes.
Thank y'all for celebrating my birthday with me.
It's always nice to celebrate my birthday with my dragoons.
Like having a little party with all of you guys and
everybody who came to the concert.
Also, a lot of you guys came back from the concert.
I'm glad all of you guys enjoyed the concert.
A lot of love was put into it.
So I'm happy that you guys all enjoyed the experience.
I wanted this concert to be like, like I said, I wanted to
be different from like a typical YouTuber concert that you
guys see a lot.
wanted to like you know tackle this theme i felt like this
was a great this was a theme you don't normally see in
vtuber concerts and you know it's i it was a lot of songs
that a lot of people grew up with a lot of nostalgia uh it's
my turn to nostalgia bake you know it's the year of
nostalgia baiting everybody gets sequels now malcolm in the
middle um uh big band theory um all the It's the era of
nostalgia, babe.
Like,
yeah.
So, quality was super chat.
Thank you.
Do you remember?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I knew I watched Minions vs.
Monsters yesterday.
And so, that's why I wasn't streaming yesterday.
I forgot to tell you.
That's why I didn't stream yesterday.
I watched Minions vs.
Monsters.
Someone talk to the Remember Bears?
Because if you guys didn't know.
um the guy who voices silk park character slash randy slash
remember berries um he was also in again he got casted again
in the minions movie uh for the kufulu guy um so uh he was
back so that's why i was like oh yeah so that's why i also i
went to the vip adult theater so it was a full house filled
with adults and i drank um i had a i had alcohol while I was
watching I was watching minions versus monster that's right
I got myself some hard liquor while watching it yeah um so I
watched minions for it was a good movie it was a homage to
like for those who didn't know it was crazy this movie was a
homage to like films like film like basically filmmaking in
general so they had like Charlie Chaplin like references as
Charlie Chaplin the black and white films to sound for sound
movies to warn their like they had a lot of references if
you knew like i used to like take film classes um for fun
just because i was i thought it was i don't know i just
thought it was fun and um i was interested in like just like
i was like it was just one class but it was very interesting
so like i knew a lot of these references of how hollywood
and stuff so it was very um it was a very fun film i want to
say the best film but it was fun film um uh but yeah news i
will say um i think i've watched every despicable me slash
minion film in theaters except for despicable me three was
it three where he had a twin or was that four i watched
every film i watched every despicable me movie in theaters
except for the one where he had a twin.
I don't remember which one that was.
Come on.
That was three.
Okay, that was three.
Got almost all of them.
Oh my God.
Thank you for the rate.
I was just about to end.
I'm sorry, peanut.
Thank you for the rate.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna head off now.
Thank you, everybody, coming.
Thank you all for celebrating my birthday in LA.
And for everyone who came, I'm glad you guys had a great
time at the concert.
too at la in la and um it really i don't know seeing all
those photos seeing like um all of that and like see you
guys carry all the little dokees around and ever oh yes
forgot the we sold out the dog shits and then okay sorry
sorry here's a fake out sorry another fake out guys um but
when i was in the korean barbecue with my with the staff
like the nom's cafe staff and like this uh and like um and
then they're like joki we have some bad news we found more
dog shirts i was like no
so there was some dog shirts that were like that
unfortunately um fell out like we're just like scattered
here and there that like yeah that's when we're just we just
had leftovers that I thought we sold out we technically have
more in the storage though it's not like it's gone forever
we still have more um that was that's still at the the
warehouse but like we thought we sold all the dog shirts
that we brought to Adam Expo but there were still like a
couple there's still a couple that that thought that oh my
god that match escape us like it like was like hidden some
boxes.
Next scene, they get a super chat.
Thank you.
Or come eat rice and watch, and I watch this pickle meat
three.
It wasn't too bad.
it's a never-ending story.
But thank you to everybody that bought the dog shirts at the
venue.
Thank you, guys.
It's one step closer.
We are one step closer.
It's okay.
We're getting there.
Anyway, all right, for real, though.
For real, guys.
Thank you, everyone, for the huge support on the concert.
Like I said, it was hard.
That concert was a lot.
And I'm so happy that everyone enjoyed it so much and took
their little mini dokees.
That was the main reason why I try to make sure you can pick
up the mini dokees.
dokees because I wanted people to take the mini dokees out
on a little adventure in LA and just took pictures like have
like this is the reason why I made those little mini dokees
too because I love how you guys took pictures of like the
little adventures that you gave them and everything and I'm
glad like I said I'm happy I'm so happy that everybody loved
the concert and was able to make it to the other concert in
time too that's what I was worried about so I'm glad you
guys were able to make it to both concerts as well um and
you you technically pre-gamed at mine if you think about it
yeah you guys came to my concert to pre-game to the other
concert
there was alcohol there too um and so it i'm just and i'm
really happy that all like so many people enjoyed it like
that's all i want i just want you guys to have a good time
and it's great to see people saying how uh how this was like
one of the best concerts they went to in person and i'll
create more of these those types of experiences for all of
you guys um obviously there's always time there's always
room for improvement i'm always looking for improvement i'm
very hard on myself when it comes to this um um and uh you
know like i said i'm always I'm always I always want to make
sure you guys have the best experience I'm always just super
hard on myself because I know there's always something I can
do to improve and I hope you guys have a great rest of today
and thank you guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check thank you uh oh that's sorry my brain is so frazzled
right now as always I raise to hydrate posture I get them
around get that blood flowing you say it for me head to bed
guys you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys Bye!